This fucking podcast was brought to you by me leaving the laptop volume on
this podcast.
Updated Url for audible.com if you go to audible.com forward slash show,
you will know what I'm about to talk about.
Ladies and gentlemen,
what am I about to talk about?
You know what I didn't do the other day,
the last time my dumb ass did the podcast and did a,
a,
an audible add.
I forgot to say the URL.
No,
I thought I did.
I think I said it at the end right,
but it didn't say at the beginning.
So I instance audible is a,
uh,
a very nice customer and uh,
I think they have a great product.
We're going to do it again.
So,
um,
audible.com/joe you go and,
uh,
you get audible free for 30 days and you get a free audio book.
Uh,
it's pretty fucking bad ass.
I've been reading this book called sex at dawn and uh,
it's a Duncan Trussell.
Uh,
turned me on to it.
This guy,
Dr. Christopher Ryan,
we're going to get him in on the podcast.
Really,
really interesting stuff about how monkeys used to fuck Joe d as in how it
turned us into people.
Fascinating edge and Mccain Yourself,
ladies and gentlemen,
and do it through audible.com.
The beautiful thing about audible is that not only do they have a fuck load of
audio books that you can listen to,
but they also have a thing called whisper sync for the Amazon kindle fire.
And uh,
it's amazing what it,
what it is,
is you read the book,
say if you're reading it on the kindle and then you get in your car,
it's syncs up to your phone.
So it plays you the audio version read by professional actors.
Incredible.
It syncs up to where you left off.
So if you leave off the beginning of page 34,
boom,
that's where it picks up in your car.
It's awesome.
It makes commuting so much better as does podcasting.
And you listen,
we hear that from you people all the time and we appreciate the fuck out of it.
We really,
really do.
I think Jamie's about the lock the door and he should,
um,
but the uh,
audible.com um,
sponsorship is for me it's a,
it's a great one because audible has done a lot to support comedians.
There's a lot of comedy shows and comedy CD's and stuff that's on audible and
back in the day,
audible when the Internet was really young,
autobot was taking a lot of chances with comedians and like I know they had like
Steve Marr and a couple of other guys,
they did like weekly shows that they upload it to audible,
like all the new stuff of the week.
They tried to do like five or 10 minutes of new standup each week and you know,
it was a lot,
a lot of pressure to do,
to come up with like that kind of material that you'd want recorded.
But audible is pretty bad ass.
Uh,
I liked that.
audible.com forward slash joke go there,
you get 30 days for free and you get a free audio book.
You fuckers fuckers were also Bhante as always,
always buy on it.com.
I'm on at.com makers of supplements,
fitness equipment and even food.
You'd have to lock it yet man,
he's not done.
He's got to fix something.
Um,
if you,
uh,
you go to on it,
you will see all the various new things that we sell.
Include a,
we have Madison balls now and wall balls,
these balls you throw up against the wall and these things called steel bells.
They're really awkward and heavy and you pick them up and fucking slam him and
throw him battle ropes,
kettlebells and all this stuff that we sell is the type of fitness equipment
that you're seeing.
If you're watching like any shows,
uh,
where uh,
you see UFC countdown shows where guys have to do these brutal strength and
conditioning workouts in what they're doing by,
there's a lot of guys who don't like doing this stuff.
A lot of guys just like to do their martial arts workouts and,
and that's it.
But the guys who are doing strength and conditioning,
they have a significant advantage.
And that advantage is,
this stuff is fucking brutal,
but it puts your body in incredible shape for work.
If you do,
if you can get through a kettle bell workout,
like the Keith Weber Kettle Bell workouts that we sell,
uh,
on,
on it,
those are the ones that we had talked about for a long ass time before we had
ever gotten them to sell.
There were so good.
I just kept talking about it wasn't,
it wasn't that I was,
uh,
you know,
trying to court them as a,
as a client.
I'm just completely being honest.
His Kettle Bell DVD beats my ass.
It's called the extreme kettle bell workout cardio workout.
Um,
it's fucking wicked.
I mean,
it's the best cardio Kettlebell workout I've ever done.
It's a mother fucking heart attack with a 35 pound kettle bell for real.
It's a heart attack.
It's bad ass.
I love it.
That's Anon at.com with all along with Alpha brain,
shroom tech,
all the various supplements,
all of them are explained on,
on at.com.
If you don't know what the fuck we're talking about.
And if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you save 10% off any and all of those supplements do you dirty bitches.
Joey motherfucking Diaz is here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
and this is our 300th episode.
Praise Shiva.
Praise Odin.
The gods have aligned and brought us to 300 fucking episodes.
Read bad high five.
We did it.
Here we are and we're here with the baddest motherfucker on the history of the
universe.
Joey Go.
Go is
[inaudible].
I got one thing to say.
First of all,
I've got a bunch of things to say.
I got um,
I want to say Skullcandy thanks for sending us these awesome headphones,
but it's called candy.
Why do you have a fucking button that shuts him off?
Deejaying this,
this button is silly.
That's a silly bitch of a button.
It's just because that we constantly accidentally hit it and we think something
more like insane as broke and said,
then we're like trying to fix something that doesn't,
yeah.
The podcast was delayed by a solid 20 seconds because I was scrambling to try to
out how to fix that shit.
Last night,
a Dj saved man,
Joey Coco Diaz will be joining me and our pal Douglas Stan hope who will also be
on the podcast this Saturday afternoon.
And Joey Coco Diaz will be joining me and Doug Stanhope and honey honey band
Friday at the end of the world basically sold out.
There's like single tickets left,
um,
that are scattered around the room.
People coming in from all over the world.
We're very excited and we're hoping that if we have a good show,
the world won't actually end.
I think we can keep it together.
I think we can keep this simulation guy that Joe Diaz.
Wait,
thanks.
I hope so brother.
I hope so.
I want it to end so much fun fucking though,
but a lot of things have been happening,
so you know,
we should happen this.
She is so maybe,
yeah,
I don't think it's going to end.
I think it's just changed how we'll live in,
there's something that we were talking about before the show,
um,
where,
uh,
there's a page that shows all the various,
I,
I retweeted it.
It shows all these school shootings and what drugs the young kids were on,
whether it was a 14 year olds on Prozac,
Prozac,
whether it's a pack sills,
Zoloft.
I mean,
it's incredible.
If you look at the history of school shootings from,
you know,
I mean it goes all the way back to 1992 p kids that were on drugs that were in,
in,
in the 1990s,
there were putting people on,
on different,
different meds and some of these kids want it being school shooters.
Does that mean the kid wasn't already fucked up and wasn't already really
troubled to begin with?
And maybe the fucking drugs kept him from doing something even more horrible
earlier.
I don't know.
But you've got to look at this.
This thing is crazy.
It's like 2008 school shooting Paxil withdrawal,
but PROZAC withdrawal rather.
Um,
2008,
PROZAC and Paxil,
Zoloft,
Zoloft Med for depression meds for depression.
Medford pressure,
withdrawal,
antidepressant,
Zoloft,
and this is like each school shooting.
Each one of these kids is on one of these fucking things.
SSRI meds for depression,
antidepressant.
I mean I'm,
I'm reading off like virtually every school shooting.
I mean this is a fucking carets he situation.
If every one of those shooters is on psych meds,
does that,
does that mean that the psych meds are causing it?
No.
That doesn't mean that it doesn't,
but what it does mean is that you got it.
You're dealing with some very fucked up people,
which we know by the results,
but that that connection should at least be investigated and that needs to be,
we need to understand what the fuck is going on,
even if it's only a small percentage of the population who have these psychotic
episodes.
How many people have like very similar thoughts and don't act?
How many people
have like extreme feelings of detachment and don't report it?
What is that map showed that people that aren't,
are not on anything.
Also like you're like no prescription medicine.
Oh,
this one is just all of the different school shootings that were connected to,
uh,
to kids on drugs.
Let's go with that though.
That's a really good point.
If it was like 90% not on something.
Yeah.
Well I don't think so because there would have to be truly shootings.
There's so many in the,
in the PROZAC ones,
it's like,
come on.
How many have there been?
There's so many in,
in the a antidepressant.
When school shootings from kids,
not on antidepressants.
Joey,
did you have a lot of people in your,
your school growing up like that brought guns or did you ever have anything like
that
thinking I was just thinking about Joe's age because I wanted to ask Joe a
question.
When you wanted the eighth,
seventh,
and sixth grade,
if a kid went to the meds office to take meds and the date,
then we all told he was fucking crazy.
It was crazy when I was a kid.
I never heard of all of these pills to lately.
Me Personally,
when a parent tells me,
I think kids on something,
I want to smack the parent.
But again,
it's none of my business.
How you raise your child.
I have my own problems.
But uh,
you're given these,
like I told Joe,
you're giving these kids pills and it really is because you're not working on
parenting.
You're cutting yourself short.
You're bit whenever the fuck it is.
Your kid needs attention.
Somebody told me that with children you have to put the time in now or if not,
you have to put the time in later.
And he goes,
when he had his daughters,
both his daughters,
he was very involved.
You know,
we sit and talk like men on this podcast.
After the situation on Friday,
I read everybody.
I didn't say anything on Twitter,
on Facebook.
I'm not one of those peoples can let's talk shit because I don't know what the
fuck's going on.
I wasn't there.
But I will tell you where I was between the ages of seven and 10 my mother was
married to a very violent men,
not towards me or my mother,
but he was very violent.
I he,
I seen him shoot somebody in the leg when I was eight.
Shoot,
not hear about it.
Knocked the,
somebody told me I shoot him,
throw to wicked,
beaten some people and I seen him stab but few people,
his weapon of choice was having a knife.
Do you know when I was eight Joe,
I had to live in,
I had,
my mother had that big house with the bedroom,
but she made my bedroom.
They had it and I was very scared of sleeping up there and I would throw a
tantrum like any other child who eight or seven you have children were scared.
We heard the Boogie man,
if you not,
this guy used to give me a gumball.
The silence when you were an eight give me a gun with the silence and Sunday
ain't no spirits.
If you see a spirit,
you shoot him and I put the thing down next to him and I go to bed and he'd come
up in the morning before my mother come up and they go give me the gun back,
give him the gun with the fucking silence.
I've been ashamed to tell this story,
but I have to admit you ever seen me fucking,
you ever see me with a weapon?
A knife,
a gun?
It's crazy.
You read,
man.
Have I ever taken away to me in a way?
A minute.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute though.
Wasn't there a Jay Morris situation?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but I didn't have a gun.
You told him you had no,
I had a gun
three doors away,
but I didn't have it on me.
But I still have that gun.
Was it what happened in that?
It doesn't matter what what,
what I'm putting doesn't matter.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
It's a great story.
You've never ever seen me.
You know I never snapped one had a double o seven rife.
Which your generation,
remember I remember those nights like a buck knife we'll fucking wouldn't handle
it.
Actually said double seven double oh seven when he carried in his fucking
painter's pants in the 70s when you wore a paint,
this pants wasn't,
doesn't mean that you were a painter.
It means you were back and fucking a knife.
That would stab your fucking throat off.
Well,
if you're in Arizona and you see a gentleman with a fanny pack with a fanny pack
is a gun in that,
oh my God.
You know,
especially if he's got like his shirt tucked into his pants.
I was raised around weapons from that age.
I was raised around drugs and that 15 whatever.
I had a bad situation that happened in my house and I was still connected with
weapons or whatever.
You know what?
It never gave me the urge you to take a weapon and shoot somebody or whatever.
As angry as I was at the world.
But I guarantee if I had thrown some kind of drug on me at the age of 12 and 13
I would have possibly been able to do something like that.
So there's different variables here,
Joe.
I was raised around weapons.
So for them to say it's a weapons fought breaks my fucking heart.
That's not fair.
I was raised around weapons and I'm unstable.
We've all agreed on that situation in a fucking room.
So I,
when I hear that shit,
it breaks my heart.
So do you think that it's possible,
like you've been in altered states of consciousness where you went on benders
and you weren't in the right frame of mind?
You know,
could you imagine that some of these people could be on something that really
sort of disconnects them with the,
the normal every day feelings that we all have?
I mean,
we don't understand what the real developmental effects of a lot of these things
are.
We have vague ideas of whether or not it's quote unquote helping people,
but there's not a lot known about the longterm effects of raising young people
on these types of medications is,
there hasn't been hundreds of years of research done on it.
You know,
there hasn't been a lot of anecdotal evidence has been studied and carefully
reviewed.
There's a lot of people pushing shit on kids just to calm the fuck down and
they're not exactly sure what the repercussions are going to be when that guy
turns 25 18 one not stable.
We want to stay with Joseph.
I know you weren't.
I know.
I definitely was.
I don't know about red man.
I got super lucky man.
I told him I could've gone down some really bad roads,
but I found martial arts at a really early age,
so we're not,
by the time I was 15 I was completely obsessed with martial arts.
That's all I did with my time and I watch all these kids around me like
thrashing around trying to find their place in the world and not having anything
that tests and we're defines them.
And I realized very early on that it was really lucky to find the martial arts
and even though martial arts consumed me to the point where I paid very little
attention to schoolwork,
I didn't
give a fuck about schoolwork.
Dude.
I didn't give a fuck.
I was,
I had nightmares that I was going to fail and have to go back because in my
nightmares I was trying to figure out what they are.
I'll get back at all whether I'd just tell him to go fuck themselves.
I thought about telling them to go fuck themselves when I was 16 because I heard
that you can quit school when you were 16.
I'm like,
what am I getting out of this that I can't get out of books.
This is,
this is not the guy,
I guess socially.
Am I getting something out of it?
I was trying to analyze it myself,
but I barely paid attention.
All I gave a fuck was training.
That's all I cared about.
I quit.
Did you quit?
What year was it?
My senior year.
He just said,
fuck it.
I had to quit.
I needed to make a living and then I ended up going back like in,
uh,
January.
I felt really bad about quitting.
Did you get a GED or a diploma?
They fucking,
uh,
that was too political.
John was in my hometown,
so the one political John was on that pushed me.
The other political John wanted me the fuck out of that.
So by the time I got back in,
the other political Jonathan was in and they said,
I miss graduating by credit.
I had no reason to walk down and get a graduate anyway cause I had no family
that I didn't give a fuck about a diploma,
shaking somebody's hand.
But it was important to me to get a diploma.
That was a credit short and they tried to give me like a credit for football,
but they said it wasn't counting.
So I ended up having to go to summer school.
I told him to suck my dick and I got a GED in Colorado and then went to fucking
school.
And you know,
it didn't really matter to a college anyway,
so it really doesn't fucking matter to me.
It was a,
yeah,
if you can get into a community college and show good grades and then you can
get into a better college.
But at that age I thought that quit and high school was the beginning of the yet
at that age I really thought I was going to,
I did too.
I thought it was,
I went to college.
The whole reason I went to college was to,
so that people didn't think I was a loser.
It's the whole reason 100% so that I could say I'm going to college.
I had no,
no business there because again,
it was like,
that was when I was 18 and all I was thinking of most competing.
That's all I was doing.
I was obsessed.
I was not,
I'm not,
I was not good at like doing a bunch of different things.
You know,
like if I had a girlfriend,
like one of my province was my first girlfriend in high school.
When I first started banging,
I cease and desist at all of their activities.
I mean,
you all do everything.
Yeah.
But nothing,
I didn't do anything else.
I'll just hang.
I was obsessed and hanging around with this car.
I think I left back in the seventh grade for it because I fucking,
I'm that stupid.
No,
the fucking monkey drove me fucking nuts.
A monkey.
I know.
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
Go ahead.
So what happened?
Did you quit everything?
Karate.
I quit talking to me for months,
for months.
I didn't train.
And then I finally,
I don't know whether I got tired of fucking her or,
you know,
I just came to my senses.
I got back there and started training again and then,
and then I became obsessed with that again and not as much her.
Was that your first love,
that same broad or yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
That was my first love to the one that fucked me up completely.
Well I had two,
two at the same time during that period of time,
like a,
a sort of an on and off situation when one of them wouldn't work out.
Then the other one would somehow or another magically like wind up being single
at the same time.
Like went for like a couple of went back and forth.
But one was like,
Whoa,
I was way closer to one than the other.
One was actually really cool.
She's pretty smart,
interesting check from a single mom.
She had like,
she was,
she was interesting.
She was smart,
you know,
and she was,
um,
she went on to be,
uh,
like sports for the government or some shit like that.
So she did some computer work for the government.
Forget what we were looking at early twenties and she was explaining to me what
she does.
It's very,
very,
you know,
very interesting to like be in touch with someone from the time he knew them
when you were 14 he just fingering each other and jerking each other off too.
Like all of a sudden she like works for the government,
you know a grown up human being.
It's like all right.
I guess we're a real live adults now but with the one I was in love with,
I used to go roll this game with her and shit on the weekends and we were
holding hands.
It wouldn't give me the push and she just let me dry it up.
Dry humping earth,
wind and fire every fucking after though.
But she was in love with Donny Osmond but I was going to have the show with
marina on Friday nights.
I was going to fuck.
Donnie has husband done,
but that was my competition.
Then when she realized you couldn't have Donny Osmond,
she let me give it a little tap and it's set me off dog.
It's amazing that I never got this girl pregnant.
We didn't use any birth control.
We're just pulling out.
I was like,
you know,
15 or 16 or something like that and we fucked all,
hey,
we fucked pampering.
Dang.
If there was some isolation,
we were fucking while she was on and be like,
what do you think that is?
Cause there's a lot of times where it's like that where it's like,
fuck you got lucky.
You got lucky.
We'll see of acid
savage ass.
No,
I wasn't eating ass
first of all back then it wasn't the same because ass was like herring.
There was like,
you know you went to,
if you went down on a girl,
like there's fucking hair everywhere.
No,
nobody did anything about it.
They didn't trim it.
They just let it go.
It was California Bananas,
Dude.
I dated a girl when I was in my really early twenties and I took her pants off
and I was just shocked.
I was flabbergasted.
I was like,
how could you just leave it like that?
Like there was red,
she was Italian and it was ridiculous.
It was an asshole to pussy all the way up to the size of the thighs.
It was just chaos.
It was unbelievable chaos between that pussy,
that ass little Wang.
It smells like a garlic hot dog.
Why is that repulsive?
I love it.
But what is it about like asshole hair and all that stuff that's gross.
What is it about that?
But it is girls shave their legs,
you know,
girls aren't having hair.
All of it thought it was disgusting.
When you eat that pussy and it's swampy and his hair is shit all over your
fucking face.
I'm telling you,
someone said that women started shaving their legs during World War Two because
that's when they,
um,
they were running out of panty hose.
Does that make any sense?
Yeah,
kind of.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
When did women start shaving their legs?
As soon as they realize that men would fuck them harder if they didn't have hair
on their legs.
Right?
Yeah.
Gas.
I don't mind a little not you know,
right pussy but the worst is like there's so many things going on like yeast
infections and things like that.
Girls you date and Sonia,
you know we're used to infections come from and one of the big,
one of the big reasons why I'm asked to vagina.
There's a little of that and there's all that's actually more dangerous cause
that's like ECO law.
You can have like real problems like you could die,
you can have like Septic Cosa brought out from the inside.
What I was going to say is it's from other dudes shooting loads into the same
hole.
Really?
Yup.
Oh yeah.
It's nature letting you know she's a skank.
Wow.
It does happen with some girls for whatever reason.
It's like a warning sign that you know those,
those loads of battling to the death in there and as they're battling to the
death in there,
she gets like some sort of a weird sort of a
back to,
you know,
men,
men can get yeast infections.
Also I found out and I felt like I was googling it to see if I had one once and
then it's like,
oh,
you could just use doctor Scholls.
You know if you're a guy,
so like if you can use like foot spray on it to kill it if you're a guy,
but don't do it if you're a girl because you have to spray it inside.
Hmm.
I have fucked women from every aspect of life.
What I'm saying is like Baus Coke fucking hole.
It's coke.
You know airplanes.
You know we've gotten a big suck this comedians after clubs and fuck them with
no condoms.
I'll tell you what,
I never got a disease.
You know I got diseases from college girls.
Those are the filthiest little motherfuckers up there,
those little cake going,
I get fucked and they don't remember fuck's.
Those are the filthy mother fuckers.
I got that chlamydia shit when you had that yoga coming out of here and then I
gave it to the chick [inaudible] when I was 28 I called from a waitress at the
broker joker.
Why was a a a comic that I was the House Mc on Tuesdays.
Where is it then?
Bolga there.
That's why I started comedy.
It's called the broker.
The broker in all right.
They used to have the broker joker and on Wednesday nights it was spot Tucson
that was sponsored by,
what was the other beer in the nineties?
Beside uh,
uh,
Heineken Germany?
No,
no.
Jack's Beck's Beck's comedy night.
So the banks would give me a dude.
It fell off back to yet they were fucked.
They made me the house
and I banged her in the fucking and I banged her first for like a year.
I was in love with this college chick.
I kept getting itches.
This chick had more fucking diseases when they ain't got to eat that little
monkey.
And you could see like with the chlamydia leaked that a monkey in the dry paint
after you paid it and the fucking monkey just dries on the wall and shit like
that.
I looked at and I didn't even go to the doctor either.
That time I got clean.
I didn't know til years later I asked somebody what happened to like idiot,
there's nobody died.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm going to the doctor in those days I was 28 no,
too busy slinging thing.
What did they do for you?
They give you a shot at these cause your body fight off if you don't talk about
mania.
Yeah,
I don't know.
That's way to get a doctor.
I didn't go to the doctor.
I didn't find out till years later when I was embarrassed and I ask somebody
coked up and said,
listen,
when you get that little white yoga that comes out of the middle level that
though like it's chlamydia or some shit like,
oh see I thought they were,
because I had the word Clinton it.
You couldn't get it.
That's Ohio suburbs.
14 year old science.
It's saying
penis dribbles or something like that.
You can't like if you have a vagina,
you couldn't get [inaudible] dot com the Korean roommate that when she went to
New York gave me something too,
but that was the very disease.
I was like a rash.
We,
I just scratched my fucking skin off my nut sack.
And what'd you do about that?
I had at that time I had to go to pharmacy and he goes,
don't you need help?
So how do I do in pharmacy and pull your Dick out?
No,
I showed him
nuts.
You know what?
Cvs is completely different than here.
Oh,
the bio.
This is in north boulder by the hospice.
So you go
take a look at my notes.
I knew the dude,
I know he started blows.
I would bring him a rock from time to time,
like free medical advice.
So fuck it.
That was so you showed him your balls and he said you've got to go to the doctor
and get like a cream.
So I went to the doctor in Bolton.
I told him the truth that I got it from and they go,
what did he say was some skin disease?
Something in like the ring warmth.
Uh,
cousin.
Whoa Pussy.
Ringworm.
When I was a kid from playing in the weeds and Jersey dirty.
That's unprecedented.
So that's a dark,
dark itching getting that sack.
That won't go the fuck away.
You rip that motherfucker up part dog.
Yeah,
I knew a lot about a ringworm because of Jujitsu.
If you're,
if you're getting ringworm,
here's one thing you don't want to do.
Don't use antibacterial soap.
You've gotta be real careful about that shit.
When you use antibacterial soap,
it's okay if you're going to like do operations on people and Shit,
but the issue with antibacterial soap is it kills all the good bacteria in your
body too.
So you support this.
There's a company called defense soap and they make this soap that has all
natural oils like tea tree oil,
eucalyptus oil,
all like natural oils that keep the bad shit from growing but help the healthy
shit.
It's all like,
it promotes good flora,
good skin flora,
but that's fine.
Well like Kaka it for your fucking skin.
Takapuna shut juice.
You fucking drank a couple of Jujitsu
back into the probiotics.
In fact,
that's a probiotic off the list.
That's another,
yeah,
biotic.
They say you could actually like Sauerkraut and yet like certain types of
Sauerkraut,
like for vegans or people don't want to eat animal products.
They can get probiotics that way,
but you know,
they're just,
it's like what size animal you're not allowed to eat.
Cause at a certain point in time you're eating some fucking live in fungus.
You're eating some little,
some little microbes
there that are running around.
I guess they can't cry since they can't cry.
You're allowed to eat them like you're allowed to eat ants.
If you're a Vegan.
Can you have like chocolate covered ants?
Probably not living thing.
Hmm.
Aunts,
no microbes.
Yes.
You're allowed to eat the microbes.
You can eat living things if you're gonna,
if you're gonna have probiotics,
you got to eat something that's alive.
It just can't complain.
So you just fucking eat it.
You know they sell bugs.
Now Abercrombie or know urban outfitters,
you know the clothing store,
they have like chocolate covered bugs that you can buy.
Like what?
You know how you're waiting to check out and have like all that shit that you,
they want you to buy at the last second,
you know.
So that's,
cause they figured they'd made you retarded from that spray.
They're spraying and that plays to keep it stinks.
Know you're thinking Abercrombie,
urban outfitters,
urban outfitters is different.
Like Abercrombie is the one where that music super loud and it has like a stupid
Cologne smell everywhere.
Gay guys all over the wall,
they're like hugging girls and they all have perfect hair and it smells so bad.
Like that place is you ever go to Ambercrombie offense and be ever rope you in.
So that's what happens when you have daughters.
Someone needs to go into Abercrombie and it's like,
it's like going into this conch cows.
That's what it's like.
It's like,
you know,
someone's got to clean up the skunk shit.
I'll do it.
All right,
Like you're going into an area where you know you can only last a certain amount
of time.
Okay.
If you go into the gap or whatever,
going to buy a pair of Levi's,
you can sit down in that store for an hour and read a book if you had to,
but you go into that Abercrombie and Fitch,
that mother fucker is toxic gas.
It's all stinky smells and it's a stinky smell.
It's not good for you.
Seriously.
It's like it's like a Glendale 24 hour fitness locker room.
Is that how they do it?
Is that I'm a fucking do it.
How they want to do it is that they're going on purpose.
I asked this girl was working there.
I go,
why do you keep spraying that stuff?
She goes,
they make us,
they make us every like on the hour you have to walk around and spray this shit.
Whoever owns that store is more raw.
The advantages of being two weeks.
You don't have to go to this place and no,
I don't have my size and any of those fucking so where do you go to church?
You a specialist.
You know what bro?
You can not.
You don't know what you're buying anymore until you bought.
You'd like something you buy,
you try it on.
Sometimes I'll get a pair of pants and then 42 they fucking fit.
Sometimes 42 don't go around my leg.
It depends whether the two European cod or it's an American car.
I bought clothes when I go to Tennessee,
everything fucking fits in Tennessee.
They make the clothes smaller.
So do you follow him?
Say Anything in Tennessee?
I fit in a one X.
Oh really?
That's interesting because there's a lot of big people and take the people to
make double x little bit bag rager.
So when you go home and mom La Loche thank and Cida blacks,
it's the outlets like Macy's.
Okay.
When you go to Macy's here and you see a two x,
you'll put it on anyway,
it's breathing.
I go to Houston and get that same two x.
It's a fucking three X.
Right?
So it's very weird.
Largely across the country.
Who has the biggest people?
Doesn't it was the fattest.
It's between Houston and Dallas blessing.
How can you fucking be skinny in a town where the breakfast is?
Those fucking hot dogs and a bunny.
You can't lose because I could listen as a stoner.
I don't give a fuck what type of fitness you're and you got to stop over there
once a week.
I'll tell you why.
When you go to Texas and you fucking sit down and they serve you a 24 ounce
steak,
you know like,
God damn it.
Fuck it.
I'm in Texas.
Let's just do this.
It seems like what you're supposed to be doing there when you're looking over it
and dude,
next to you,
it is giant belt buckle and a cowboy hat.
It gives you the nod as he's cutting into the meat.
Do you know what was the deadliest place we ever went to as a restaurant?
Brian?
When we went to Houston and after that night we all went to that fucking place
with the old guy and we sat in a table like this and they brought his Greek food
and they brought us to Greek pizza places.
Great.
Let's get it out of the fucking way.
Babies as Susan,
the name of it.
No,
no,
no.
It's a Greek place.
It's a,
in fact,
I just got an invite to his birthday was the name of that place.
Like the kid was a curling NGOs to come by these fevers.
BBDS is a girl's clothing store.
Bb,
BB.
But the fucking guy in the daytime used to assault people.
They had a way to use the soap people.
He's really,
and he would give you the weight,
the fucking thing.
And he'd come up to you like five minutes when he wanted for breakfast.
I don't know.
Your thing is diabetes that make up your mind fucking yell at people and the
people liked it.
They had an old school waitresses there too,
right?
Old School.
They were a hundred a piece.
Like if you were,
if you were younger than they do not apply.
They would make them up.
No plastic surge like that Ag.
We seen the baseball commercial like that.
These one women that were 80 dog and the best thing about Greeks is that like
Jews,
but even better,
they don't accuse up money or stealing or nothing,
but let's just,
let's not fuck white white dad.
Let's just put my mother behind the register,
right?
They always have the cooks mother behind.
Why?
Why take that chance and that bitch will not go home and my line,
you go before pool at seven she's dead and at the pool,
she's still there.
She's sleeping against the thing.
You've got to bring the balance.
You get,
Oh,
I'm reading glasses on them bitches or put that Greek mothers there.
Those motherfuckers are there 12 hours shifts.
Yeah.
That was that place.
That place was very,
that you actually like that think
he had a couple of those places.
He had like two or three of those fucking rolls.
That one crazy flood.
There's one of the girls who was a waitress at the laugh stop sent me a photo of
where that old hotel where we used to stay at eastern?
Yeah.
Was the,
what was that parkway?
The Allen Park.
Highland Park in,
is that what it is?
The Allen Park and it was,
was so flooded.
It was,
it was like the,
the entire,
like highway was an ocean and it was like a big river.
It was crazy.
Like,
I don't know how it happened.
How he got so flooded though.
What the fuck happens?
That a city can get that flooded.
But that place was gone.
But that,
that place was a staple for like a standup comics and crazy stories on the road.
I have this crackhead dude just insisting that I knew,
I knew where Eddie was.
This is like pre Eddie Bravo,
you know like a,
I was there and I'm walking around and the guy,
he goes,
come on man,
you know where Eddie is?
Where's Eddie?
And I was like,
dude,
I do not know Eddie.
Come on man.
Wait Eddie,
where had he had man,
come on man.
Come on man.
Like crazy and shaking and shit and just this dude had to find this guy and they
was just walking around knocking on doors like trying to find the guy who sells
the crack.
That was the only hotel.
You go back to your hotel room,
this home,
your hair a little bit,
get a bit and just sit in front of your whole tone and doing the morning within
15 minutes.
Some of you your walked by.
Yeah,
you drink a beer.
Come on on them.
My Room mixing it a little rip now heroin and stuff.
I'll tell you what though is another thing about that place.
If you went down to Allen Park in and the girl was willing to go back there with
you,
she's not,
she's not going to play games.
Okay.
You're taking it on a dingy as creepiest pots on earth.
She's she DTF.
All right.
She's like looking for a spot just as much as you are and you'd say this could
come on.
Nobody's Eddie.
Yeah,
man.
Like don't worry.
Don't worry about him.
This door is an inch thick of solid cardboard.
There's no way it's going to get to us while we're naked.
I was just thinking about that meal.
You know how big that meal was and how we were done.
At one point we were like,
we're done.
And we're like,
we had eight people at the table.
You're friends with that from Dallas.
What's his name?
The Nice Kid.
Flash WIC.
They were all there and we were ready.
Here's the first Rogan board circle jerk and they all put in.
They came up and put those cheese,
those Greek pizza and what's that flame on the cheese?
[inaudible] cheese.
What's the called?
Stop fast
with them.
My locked us juice.
Yeah,
they had those Dolomites.
It's not Dolomites.
That's the fucking,
that's the pimp.
Dolomites the pimp.
What are those things do the,
the leaves.
The grape leaves.
Stuffed grape leaves.
It was the best of us.
They'll be whatever.
Oh,
those are fucking
fucking,
when are you ever more hungry though?
That after two shows,
when we do two shows on a Friday or Saturday night,
we eat like unbelievable amount to eat.
You go back to your room and eat your fucking stomach.
It's horrible how fucking hungry you are three and you got to get something like
that.
Even like approaching anything will work and you'd go to fucking sleep.
But what wears you out more than doing two shows?
Is there anything where you went like when you have to do to headlining shows,
have you been doing that lately?
Yeah.
That mentally where the fuck up?
Right.
It's a lot of talking.
What are you doing an hour,
you doing an hour each.
Shelf 50 you know,
even when you do sets around town,
if you'd do a three sets and one that is 15 fucking minutes are set.
Right,
right.
You but the third set you're like,
it's amazing how sometimes it's set flies by and sometimes a set takes a long
time but it really does fly by.
But like,
it's just amazing comedy,
the whole,
the whole mechanics of it.
It's getting weirder and Weirder,
but I love it more now than I,
but you know,
don't you feel like the more you do it,
the better it gets,
but the more out of your hands it is.
It's like,
God,
this is fucking crazy thing.
He's got a life of own.
Yes.
Keep doing it.
Keep getting up there.
Right.
You're talking,
there's so much shit going on that you,
you know,
you don't,
you just,
I dunno,
it commonly is a lot of fun.
Lately I've been having a lot of fucking phone with lates.
No shows.
It's the best job ever,
man.
It's the best job ever for us.
It's the best job ever.
You know,
I even miss getting lake on planes the last three weeks I've been home.
I Miss Getting,
I'm fucking plans.
Like I really miss getting even a little flight from Burbank to San Jose.
You know what I'm saying?
Like on a Thursday night,
like I was pulling those Thursday nights.
I love that shit guys.
There's an adventure to our job that,
uh,
is one of the things that's real exciting about it.
Like our last trip to Austin,
there's a lot of adventure to our job.
They're always this venture for me.
Tomorrow night during my first black room,
I don't know how to do it.
I went to tip jelly there.
Here's a tip,
being able to run as soon as you get off stage.
That's important.
Have a nice exit strategy and start off strong.
Started off strong.
You have to start off strong,
but you also have to be relaxed.
If you stutter,
they will attack.
They will go after silly and goofy and like that pill.
They'll like that.
But you also have to be smooth with your words.
You have to be well prepared.
They are.
When in Rome,
they appreciate like for real,
but black crowds are more likely to appreciate good showmanship.
Oh really?
And good.
Somebody has a really good entertainer,
but they're also more critical.
So they will,
they will come down on you if you start stuttering,
if you start stuttering,
white people give you a chance to recover.
Right?
Black people.
Not so much.
Wow.
Let's see.
Bullshit.
I pay my the fuck I paid to see you get some food.
I started in a black room but the biggest bombing,
but I never got back on a black stages in a black room.
Not to,
not to interrupt you or to get this off the subject.
What we're talking about,
black people,
famous black people and drugs.
I guarantee you,
I will bet each of you a hundred bucks and I'm no genius cause I don't know much
about the pill world,
but I guarantee you Katt Williams just problem all started with Adderall.
You think so?
Because after you don't do Adderall,
you God was watching something when you say Adderall because I was watching
something on discovery where a guy went from Adderall to speed to meth because
he felt that,
wait a second,
if I'm doing this,
what will speed too?
He was like an accountant.
He was like a fucking,
you know,
I never fucked with Adderall.
So I just hear what people are saying that you could write better.
You write a ton better,
you do all this shit better.
So I've already been around the block with things that make things better,
so I don't need,
you know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
Reminded me of cocaine immediate.
That's what I'm saying.
Like I felt like I had drips in my mouth.
I could see a person doing that are all and doing two bumps and just losing it.
I have a friend and I believe he's on the Adderall and he's been acting very
erratic lately.
More and more like over the last like six,
seven months.
I don't see him that often.
I see him,
you know,
every few months or so,
he's,
he's starting to get a little bonkers about our one friend.
I'm talking about a friend.
I'll tell you who it is when the show's over and we stop recording,
we'd go outside and stand behind a car.
Went friends off it.
I,
no,
no.
Um,
I don't know which friend you're talking about.
Uh,
up north.
We just saw him in,
uh,
no,
that guy.
You're right.
Yeah.
That guy is off it.
Yeah,
that guy.
That guy's a way smarter,
Dude.
And the dude.
I'm talking about the dude I'm talking about as much dumber and he's got a
fucking problem.
Wow.
So the town,
I'll tell you after the show,
it has something.
Why do you think that cat is doing Adderall in the first question?
What makes you think maybe it's not at all,
but it's something.
I think it's cocaine and mental.
He's mixing with that gentlemen.
It's something that's Zod night with it.
Let me get this goal and now he's smoking crack with it.
You know,
I tell you guys once you start doing it and if you listen to the stories,
these people started doing it with everything else.
It don't matter you the chicken Florida that was drinking and doing the bottom
pills.
Maybe shooting pool with a fucking loud that day.
Maybe it's just trying to come up with a new hour.
Just dude,
it's just going to go all.
I seem to take out a whole new hour and I've seen the tape from Oakland.
I seen the woman when he came up with the drug bunny rabbit,
he is of his head and he just shook his head for 35 fucking minutes or whatever
and I love that one is,
but I'm telling you guys that these pills and this over the counter,
this shit on that over the counter,
this side,
what do you call it?
Pharmaceutical is oxycon opiates.
It's just killing mother fuckers.
This or all of this shit.
Just smoke fucking joints that whatever happened,
just smoked on a fucking,
I don't know.
I don't understand why no one's beat him back though.
Like how many,
how many people has he hit but you don't hear like them beating his ass.
He's seen what happens when he hits people like nothing.
He's like getting swatted by a four year old.
Like he punched the Walmart guy in the face.
The Guy didn't even flinch.
[inaudible] guiding,
go down.
The guy didn't put his hands out,
the target guy,
whatever it was,
he punched that guy in the face.
It's like nothing you've got.
The guy was like,
that was nothing like you didn't do anything to me.
What that did was obviously just scared of black people.
Was He [inaudible] himself a target?
Uh,
Sacramento.
Was he by himself?
By himself?
Okay,
so you see the video.
I see the video.
So I just pull the video I saw at what time was this?
What time did it happen in the afternoon?
That's a good question.
I can't repeat.
This motherfucker is asleep before ranking it all day.
He didn't sleep.
And do you think that's what gives him,
that's why he's uh,
so like,
uh,
like short tempered.
You run it snowflakes in the back of any motherfucker.
Why didn't you tell him when you don't sleep a dog?
When you don't fucking sleep,
you don't sleep with him?
Two nights.
Oh,
I've been there,
man.
What the fuck you talking to me like that before?
You know,
you get fucking agitated.
Confusion.
Yeah.
There's a word for that.
You become self delirious deliveries.
Yeah.
So I,
I watched that target one.
That's what I'm taking about.
He's up all night before you.
Only Times I've done,
I did coke all night and by 11 o'clock at night all night,
he just talking to this fucking guy.
The guy's got his left hand up.
Oh,
just stole on him?
Yeah,
just kind of looks at his phone and he had stolen him and then he backed up.
How many times by 11 o'clock in the morning.
In my mind I was fine.
That was fine.
I'm fine.
They can't tell.
I was told blow on that.
I'll take a shower and put gel in my hair and I'll go out there.
They can't tell.
But in your mind,
as you're walking,
do you have a year old fucking conversation in your mind?
What's coming out of your fucking head is amazing.
This guy doesn't know.
He can't tell.
That's why he walks into those places.
Banged up like that before.
That's a horrible situation.
But so do you think that's coke?
What is that?
No,
they're saying it's crack.
I don't fucking know.
It could be that right.
It could be that,
but you got to stop and spoke that it'd be 20 minutes every 20 minutes.
Sure.
You've got a pipe on,
you got to have a little porch on you.
You know what,
you got to have shit on you.
So I dunno what the fuck is these people are talking about.
We use smoke crack.
You got to smoke.
I read 20 minutes.
Who was a really hot chick from Baywatch way back in the day.
She had dark hair and she got arrested.
Well with the crack pipe or and Michigan.
She was fucking around with Don Johnson.
She looked like,
like Danielle and she was so pretty basketball with me.
I think she was a basketball.
What the hell was that Brian?
I forget what her fucking name was.
Yasmin Leaf.
She was so pretty and then all of a sudden it was just a picture of her.
She was like the first like really famous check to just absolutely fall apart in
a drug photo.
I mean look at that.
That's insane.
That bitch had been up for a year.
Look at her.
She was at one point time like she was stupid hot.
Yeah.
I wonder where she,
when she looks at now.
Oh,
poor kid.
I thought I saw on a show like the attorney,
but I don't think it was up.
Yeah,
I'm sure she's got sort of,
that's what I'm thinking.
If you smoke crack,
but after you smoked crack for 10 hours,
you just go into a zone two but you don't need it anymore.
You're like,
fine.
It really,
I don't need this shit for another hour.
You know I'm going to take a walk.
You know?
I don't fucking know Joe,
but you know what,
man,
when you're 12 you're not ready at it.
As a young man with these kids,
you're not ready at 18 how are you going to give somebody fucking all these
pills at 12 years old?
Because they have a Ddi at abd at 12 so it fucking,
you sounded red band.
Yeah.
That's what makes for interesting.
People needing to be interesting.
Your parents came to you,
so you need to study hard.
You know what?
From now on a three I'm them pick you up.
I'm going to take it to the library.
I'm going to read for an hour.
You're going to study now they just give you Adderall or whatever.
The fuck they give.
You see ADP now they just replace their fucking attention with a fucking pill.
You know,
there's so many things.
Parenting is very hard and there's so many things that you think replaces
parenting,
but it really doesn't pro,
there's nothing,
nothing to like your kid coming home at three and you being there,
you know that you call home at Green.
There was nobody fucking that.
Me Too.
And my whole life
to come up with three and there's a $10 bill and a thing and the steak cooking
up.
Take the time,
go eat motherfucker.
You know and and I,
and our generation,
you could walk around,
the neighbor's mother was there.
You caught yourself cause hey,
these fucking kid.
I mean,
what are you doing man?
You know,
it's different times.
Well it's also,
it's also some people just get a bad roll the dice.
We were talking about this yesterday that you could get a real bad roll the dice
and be in a terrible family.
You just,
unfortunately,
your mother's a junkie,
your father is a murderer.
What can you do?
You know what,
man,
I've seen a lot of those kids.
They learned from that.
Yeah,
they don't,
I don't put the blame on at 50%.
40% of how many times have you seen the attorney and you've talked to him?
It's easily attorney because his mother stabbed the father was something that
was,
he had a motivation behind it.
So,
yeah.
Uh,
I just always thought I grew up a lot of psychological problems and I'm like,
I didn't want to go shooting on my fucking classmates.
I didn't want to go through a lot of fun.
I wanted to shoot my stepfather.
That was it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know Joey,
I don't,
you know,
I don't know what the fuck that kid's life was like.
Who,
how do you know it would be really important for us,
I think as a society to try to figure out what it took to turn a person into a
school shooter and life.
I don't even want to know.
I don't,
I don't know.
I'm asking you.
Is that a lot?
A lot of guns.
There was more than one gun.
Really?
Yeah.
Nate,
if you stop and think about the Columbine shootings,
I mean we know those kids were bullied,
you know,
as kids were tortured,
did he?
That's,
that's an important point too because I think it's,
some people do not really understand how important is that their kids don't
bully people and they don't understand how devastating that could be on a young
kid psyche.
Especially if the kid's coming from an unstable house as it is and then you're
you,
you coming from a house where everything is in turmoil and people yelling at you
and you're going to school and people are pushing you around and hitting you.
It's like your life is hell.
Like that is why people will commit suicide.
The you are creating their,
their life can be a hell or it could be just the opposite.
You would go to school and that same kid says,
what's up dude?
What are you doing?
It gives you a big hug.
Now you're happy.
Something is creating that bully and it's not just human nature.
There's some shit that's going on in that kid's life that's he's trying to
express and he's trying to express on other people.
I,
when I was a kid,
a lot of people that would go around and beat people up and to a man,
every one of them got beat up at home.
Every one of them.
I had a friend,
my friend Kenny,
we used to la,
he used to love to get in fights.
Kenny would just start,
just walk up to someone and start a fight.
Like,
come on bitch,
let's go.
And they got to be like,
what?
Like put up your fucking hands.
We're going right now.
They got booked,
the fuck are you talking about?
And he would just start swinging.
He was crazy.
You know why?
Because he got the fuck beat out of him as a kid.
I didn't have that.
I did not get beat up as a kid.
And uh,
I'm very fortunate for that.
So like when I see kids that lash out like that or kids that want to beat people
up,
kids that have,
they have a different sort of a,
an anger inside of them,
they have a really irrational self destructive sort of of violence inducing
anger.
A lot of that comes from being physically abused.
Like it changes the wiring of a child's brain.
It changes the way a child associates with the people that are the most loving
and protecting of him.
It's fucking,
nope,
nope.
Nobody gave you a Spec.
You know,
look,
my dad was a piece of shit,
but one thing my dad was,
he was fiercely protective of me fiercely.
Like my cousin did something to me when I was a little kid.
My Dad picked my cousin hung by his hair.
I'll never forget it.
My cousin was like 12 or 13 and I was probably like five.
He picked him up by his hair and beat the shit out of them,
but pick them in the air by,
I'll never forget the screaming that kid was making while he was getting lifted
in the air by his hair.
So I saw a lot of violence,
but it didn't get turned on me yet.
You know,
my parents got divorced when I was five,
so I never,
I didn't,
you know,
when they split up I saw him be violent with my mother.
I saw him be violent with a lot of other people.
I saw him be violent with my cousin.
Like when I told you he pulled his hair,
but he never did anything to me,
so I missed that part.
I didn't get beat up.
So because I didn't get beat up,
my mom was a very,
very sweet person.
She was never violent in any way,
shape or form.
She never even yelled.
She barely raised her voice.
My mother was a very,
very kind person and still is.
So I missed that,
that part.
But I got to see its work in a lot of friends.
You know,
you get to,
to know when,
that's one of the things that's really weird about growing up is as you're
growing up and you realize how many people come from fucked up families,
how many people's families are fucked up.
And it's like almost everybody,
almost everybody I knew had something going on.
Either the dad was an alcoholic and they were trying to figure out how to not
get them to the drive or the,
you know,
the,
the mother fucking has a gambling problem and disappears at night and doesn't
come home until the morning or there was always fucking something.
There's always something.
It's amazing.
Our society works as well as it does.
It's amazing where as together as we really are,
if you really stop to think about what a shit job people did in raising human
beings,
did you see that?
That news a thing with Kat Williams and uh,
talking about how he's like quitting comedy and he's like crying and stuff.
It was like a news report.
Really?
Yeah.
Check this out.
Quitting standup comedy and cry.
This is after all the shit.
Yeah.
This is a December 4th I think it's due tonight.
Stand up.
Comic Katt Williams has had a controversial visit to Seattle the past few days
and tonight he's telling us his side of the store come for caught up with
Williams as he was ejected from a South Lake Union hotel.
Around 7:00 PM on Sunday,
Williams was arrested after an altercation at a nearby restaurant.
Police say he argued with customers and threatened the manager with a pool cue.
Williams is accused of then throwing a lit cigarette into a family's car,
which hit a woman in the face throwing a rock at that car and struggling with
police officers.
A group of fans claims Williams assaulted them after his performance Friday
night tonight,
Williams admitted to us he has had trouble with the law here in Seattle this
weekend.
He made a string of allegations against police and the media.
Then he told us because of his bad weekend in Seattle,
he's decided to end his standup career.
I'm just going to go ahead and announce my retirement from stand up of done.
This is
not really.
Yeah,
I,
I've,
I've already discussed it with my kids.
I wasn't really going to do it on the Seattle Street.
I was going to go to Los Angeles and do it in the offices.
I see him or live nation
and William says,
proven to be unpredictable.
So we're gonna Watch and see how this all plays out.
You see that?
He looked like that reason why,
you know,
that's,
that's something that I loved the guy.
There's a guy I love,
we all fucking bug the first special cracking me up.
I knew when he fucking was cat mat,
he'd come to the store on Sunday nights problem again,
a spot up in this month,
you know?
And I tried to put them up there and argue with Mitzi,
the whole fucking deal.
Soul to see this.
You gotta what?
What is that?
That's trucks now.
Somebody wrote a book about it.
I'm pretty sure that's true.
Wrote a book about him saying what happened?
The allegations.
I don't know.
I've never seen him smoke crack.
I've noticed.
That seems like,
that seems like a drug issue.
Well,
it's either a drug issue or it's a mental health issue.
There's something,
there was something disconnected that right?
Yeah.
I mean if it's a mental health issue and he does drugs of any kind,
it could set him off.
It's like a weird spiral.
That's powerful.
Doctor Red Band next after Oprah.
Fuck Doctor Oz,
doctor red bank and we don't have cue cards to you.
Fuck Huh.
That's amazing.
I society instead of the afterschool special,
it's doctor fucking eyes
or is Maury Povich sister was [inaudible] father
is fucked up cause sometimes I watch gates ELA in the morning to see where
there's traffic and when I get home the TV still on and it's one of those shows
and I'll make a sandwich listening to like,
you know,
so this guy took a test is not the father.
The guy will do this preplanned out dance,
Huh?
Yeah.
Those dudes breakdown bitch,
I told truck came on your tillage.
The shows are me so fucking fake.
I know so many people that were like,
alright,
we need you to come to this show.
You're going to play boyfriend and girlfriend and you're going to get in a
fight.
He's a dude.
He used to work at governors in Long Island and he used to be involved in those
shows.
And what they would do is,
uh,
that they,
they don't tell you to fake it,
but what they do is they call you up and they say,
our show is looking for a guy who is having an affair with his brother's wife.
He goes,
that's crazy.
I'm having a feral.
My brother's wife,
he doesn't even have a brother.
Next thing you know,
he's on camera.
So whatever it was,
that was the game,
they would call you up and say,
we're looking for a guy who spent his life in an Asian gang,
but he's a white guy.
You know,
I spent my life and an Asian guy and I was a white guy.
Right.
And they'll just make up nonsense.
Like a lot of those shows,
it's a hundred percent
nonsense.
It's just,
they just,
it's just entertainment.
But you know,
it's crazy.
Going back to that family thing you said like in my house,
I grew up in a fucked up house but there was a lot of love and a lot of love
came from my mom and my Stepdad was a good guy to an extreme that I meet people
who have no reason to be fucked up.
Like the people I meet,
they're like cutting like people at two phase backstabbing because people come
from perfect households who you think the parents did the work but really didn't
and they're like Connie and the two phase and they do shit to people and they
think they cute.
I would always figure out these people have no reason to be cock suckers like
me.
Like that's how I would look at myself.
I came from a fucked up house so I ain't understand.
I give myself a breather.
But this guy had two nice fucking parents are both attorneys.
This guy's the biggest piece of shit out of all of them.
But you know what?
The differences,
the people that grow up with everything that happened from the get go,
there's a real issue with self worth.
And there's also real issue with a lack of character because they're spoiled.
When you talk about spoiled kids,
you want to send them camping,
you know,
take those spoiled kids and send them out to wilderness camp.
Take those spoiled kids and make them work.
If they knew what it was,
people need to understand what struggles about,
they need to understand what labor is about.
They need to understand what effort is about,
when,
what,
how.
You can get over something and it's difficult and it builds character.
And if that never happens to you,
you don't have any character.
So while you're trying to make something happen for yourself,
you know you're trying to do it any way you can and the way you been getting by
your whole life.
It was probably bullshitting people,
bullshitting your parents.
You know the people that work for your parents probably listen to you because
you're rich and they'll let you slide and they don't develop the character.
They never have an opportunity to actually develop character.
So they there.
That's why it's not,
they're not struggling and they're not being sneaky because they're desperado.
There've been sneaky because they're weak and that's just the instinct of in man
is to try to get out of work.
The instinct in man has tried or did you do it?
Yeah,
I did it.
When we mean if you didn't,
you know,
the instinct is not to man up and go,
listen,
I'm going to be honest with you.
I didn't do it.
I fucked off.
I went out with my friends,
we got drunk and I forgot about it and I woke up late.
I'm so sorry.
You know,
I don't know what to tell you,
but that's what happened.
You know,
it's obviously a huge error,
but what am I going to do now that's,
nobody wants to do that.
So you bullshit.
Oh,
the car totally wouldn't work.
We called the police,
we thought there was a bomb in it.
You know,
you'll,
you'll say all kinds of crazy shit to get out of work.
And especially if you have a weak character,
that's amazing.
And they'll put that like,
I've been locked up with the kids that know we freeze up or something.
[inaudible] I been locked up with kids that I've seen the visitation.
I was Saturday and I've said to myself,
what did you do,
Bro?
Those are your fucking partner with you.
What the fuck did y'all,
can you do this?
Which is nice family.
The whole family would show up.
The sister,
the brother,
well,
you know about Michael Douglas's son,
right?
They got beat the fuck up Pittsburgh or something broke his leg and his fingers,
they broke his femur.
It's fucking hard to break someone's femur.
I mean,
you got to hold the leg down and stomp on it,
you know?
And this guy is fucked up and his legs in a plate now,
his fingers or Jack and it's because he somehow or another,
it was revealed that when he got a shorter sentence,
it was because he gave up a bunch of the drugs,
his own lawyer.
Fuck dumb.
Or someone fucked some.
Oh fuck.
I'm self that dude.
Yeah.
He did something.
It's Michael Douglas aside.
I mean,
Michael Douglas has been famous for a long,
he's come to the conditional,
remember the same son that's not the same fucked up at night.
No brother.
That's the brothers.
His family used to come into the store at night.
That's Michael Douglass,
his brother now,
and then this kid went to New York and was dealing in Memphis.
That doesn't look at all of those fucking famous fowl.
The kids like that.
Yeah.
Not good at once.
They found that that you're not the only way they get still loans.
Kid overdosed.
Did he really?
Not what it was at that low,
but he had a drug problem,
right?
No.
Really?
Yeah.
No,
I don't think so.
That's what they said.
I,
that's what I had heard.
Let me,
I should go with that.
So don't,
okay.
By the way,
you got to check out not the father.tumblr.com and it's just all these Gif and
masons from that,
from,
you're not the father episodes.
Yeah.
It says possible drug overdose dies from pill overdose.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know?
Yeah.
They're saying an overdose man.
Really?
Yeah.
That's what most of these sites are saying.
Whatever.
I mean,
I don't think you have to release it,
so they might not,
they might just be speculating.
I don't think so.
I was just alone would have to release why son died.
That's gotta be fucking devastated,
devastated.
These guys.
Like you know a guy likes alone.
First of all,
he's not with the wife anymore of that kid.
He hasn't forever.
He has it been a forever.
And then on top of that,
he's probably doing these movies where he's in Thailand for six months and this
place for six months.
You know he's doing Rambo and shit and flying all over the place and must be
fucking really hard to also be a father.
It's a lot of those dudes become drug addicts.
So that is true.
It's a lot of them.
Right?
They would tell me that one of those thousand oaks high school,
the big thing was heroin up there.
I bet was up there.
I bet.
Oxies when I was a fucking kid,
we smoked,
they sold joints at school.
Some people sold little hits,
a fucking Mike with that acid,
you know,
two hours a piece.
But fucking heroin,
you ain't going to send you that shit.
Cold
high school,
you know it was referring little pills and those sheets of paper that we're
asking them.
That's it values all that shit.
You had to go over the fucking bridge.
You know you had to go to Washington square park and something to get the party
started and those fucking days.
But I think those thousand oaks kids,
first of all you were like way out in the suburbs too.
And all it takes is one freak bitch to convert the whole fucking bathroom I need
to do is have one kid that's this down to do some h.
Dot.
Do some age bro.
And that some one Puerto Rican kid that's like a year older than everybody
that's been held back.
But fucking heroin bro.
He's drinking a bottle of Boone's farm.
You stole from your uncle's place or something like that.
The strawberry shit that you got and you go,
I'll never dropped that thing again.
Fucking heroin it to smoke it and I don't want a straw with a little bit of
foil.
I never even seen that type of shit.
That's disgusting.
It's gross.
And not some,
like that's like some proven stupid shit for decades.
It's not like something new like was heroin.
It's not like,
you know,
like nobody's had problems with it yet.
It's not like bath salts.
You know what I mean?
Like,
dude,
I'm telling you man,
basketballs remains like nothing even happened.
She's due a dude.
Don't worry about it.
Said some shit.
I sent Stan hope stand out,
didn't know about,
uh,
that we had McAfee on the podcast and we were,
going over it and I told him about that,
the whole bath salts thing.
He didn't know about that either.
So then I went back and I said,
I'll send you some links so you gotta you gotta you gotta read some of that
stuff.
So I went back and read some of it myself.
One of the things that McAfee said that he,
he did like a whole,
like an interview for like one of these,
a radar in line or something like that about bath salts.
But how awesome.
Pass all serious.
Yeah.
But bath salts,
are the finest drug ever conceived?
That's what he said.
Yeah.
He's now in the United States.
He's in California probably.
He confessed that he's a huge fan of MDPV,
better known as bath salts and worked for a year trying to purify psychoactive
drugs from compounds commercially available over the Internet.
This is apparently,
he says this is all bullshit now,
but in of course this sir.
Okay.
This is not an interview.
This is all based on articles online that he stuffed it.
He wrote on that a drug.
Okay.
All the,
yeah.
He's hilarious.
Yeah,
Karen Anymore Stan Hope,
but no idea though.
He didn't know that it was this though.
The whole story is this bananas?
You know what?
I lied.
There was PCP when I was in high school.
Oh yeah.
There was a,
that was a,
what I called PHC crystal,
which is really a PCP.
It was really just watered down.
Fucking piece of shit was good though.
That shit was good.
I liked it.
I type on my boxing coach when I was in my bar.
When I was in Boston,
my boxing coach got his finger bitten off when he was on PCP.
So many bent his finger off and they took his toe off because the singer was
gone.
It's like from like a,
from the first knuckle,
the knuckle to the side,
like that first stub,
this part right here,
it will still there.
The rest of it was missing.
So what they did was they took,
is not as big tub,
but the second toe they removed that toe and they created a finger.
They put the bones back in,
screwed in place,
but you couldn't get it to work.
So he hadn't permanently curved so that he can be able to throw his right hook.
So like,
you know,
he didn't want to like have a finger like that where it couldn't box anymore
because that's the only option.
The option was you could have it fully straight or you can have it permanently
correct.
So he took it permanently
book,
what am I going do with my shot?
I got it.
I fucking lifted the body.
I used,
stepped in with the right hook.
That's good night.
I'm not taking away good night.
So he uh,
he kept a finger fucking that thing going away.
Good night.
So,
uh,
I was um,
I was teaching him a taekwondo when he was teaching me boxing and uh,
he would be shuffling around with that fucking four toed foot,
three toes and no,
no,
nothing.
A big gapper,
a big floppy gapper
between,
uh,
the,
these toes over here in the big toe.
There was just one was missing and he's just trying to shuffle around and throw
that file.
Fucking
creepy hybrid,
right hook.
That was,
it was a toe.
So when he was shaking his hand,
you were shaking a little bit of a toe,
a little bit of toe was in his hand and always smelled like feet.
Oh,
it was a thicker finger,
you know,
like a mason and 83,
I had this gig running numbers from like 10 to two in the afternoon,
the hundred,
18th and third for these Puerto Rican.
I had grown up with,
I had nothing.
I had no job.
I had no direction.
So I went to him like a man.
I go,
I just need a little help.
And they would just draw me like a buck 20 a day just to go with and eat their
food.
Tall stories.
They caught me walking around the block,
go get this and wasn't that when I was like,
Nah,
what I do,
and he'll tell you we're doing it up in Brooklyn if you want to go up.
They go up to,
but it's a short day because when they switched tracks the numbers fuck up.
So I'm walking and I'm going to get a bag of a refund and those days Harlem at
really good Thai stick and I'm walking in and get this bag.
Every friend,
this chick comes out to me,
Joe Rogan cute and I'm not really checking around.
She goes,
do you want to go partners on?
So whatever.
She called it,
junk Jonestown,
what happened?
I'm like,
yeah,
I got some cute girl.
Just comes up to you and black girl,
10 30 in the morning comes up to me and says,
you want to go partners on some Jonestown town?
Because what you do is they had a bag of dope for 20 bucks,
which is refund.
And then for like three bucks you got a tray.
That's what they called them trays.
So she lets go partners on two trays and we'll split it with a spliff or
whatever the fuck he saying.
Wow.
So basically you take the reefer,
you put in a paper and then you take the train and you sprinkle the dust and the
joint.
You wrote it and you bang it up.
We started smoking this motherfucker and in the middle of this he tells me that
she's pregnant.
Why this bitch is by then she shows me a little belly.
She's like,
yeah,
but I'm booked on these trays and shit.
I didn't fuck her or nothing.
Like,
I don't know.
But I remember we hung out like from 12 till like nine o'clock that night.
Shit.
I remember taking the bus go.
God Damn.
I just smoked fucking Jones town with a pregnant fucking black tea.
That's when they would give them names and that shit,
whatever the tragedy had just happened.
Like what was the black basketball player from the Celtics?
So it was a rookie and he did coke and he done by bias.
I'm like,
the next day you go over to Harlem,
go go.
Who's got the blue?
I got the shit that killed bias mother.
Fuck.
They always did that.
That was always there.
Do you remember when we was always government?
Yeah,
weed.
It was always the government.
I got the government,
we just shit,
what was it called?
Like end 13 or so like a name for [inaudible] 17 man,
there's only 10 people in the country and then I have to get this.
They get,
they get this from the government.
Yeah,
the government.
We'd was like the best weed for the longest time.
Like if you got ahold of some government weed,
that was like some serious shit.
Isn't that hilarious?
That's how far we'd come.
You know,
there's a lot of God damn weed snobs out there and they need to relax.
Let it go.
You know what else?
People that want to tell them you never had our,
we'd shut up.
Please shut the fuck up.
Just please,
please.
There is no stronger weed anywhere now.
It's a pretty,
pretty much a saturation.
The Shit that we got an Austin or that shit.
We got an Austin,
Texas.
Oh my Jesus.
And you know what the strongest Shit I've gotten all year from Seattle,
Seattle,
when they made it legal,
they just took shit to the neck,
the Voodoo chicken and moot,
you know,
hooked me up and I was there.
They gave me this joint that was like a fucking direct.
I remember those old school operators,
you know,
they would pick up the phone operator and it was right to God just went right to
him.
He just smoked that weed.
And before I went on stage,
I remember sitting in the back room just feeling so vulnerable and so,
but so alive and in tuned to everything.
And me and a Sam AAA,
Sam Aaa was baked out of his fucking mind.
I mean it was,
it was,
it was dangerous.
Like wow,
this might be too high to talk to talk.
I'm going to tell you something.
Okay,
let's see how Oregon and Colorado,
I've always had that strong and if you look at fucking,
or we're going to run this from northern California to over me,
you know area that Oh yeah,
but you gotta Let rain that affects people.
Effects are that weed.
Oh yeah.
Cause that's outdoor weed.
Now you add some altitude,
which there is some little out the to 2000 feet up in the mount.
Ranier whatever the fuck those mountains.
I'm a geology major.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Colorado,
same thing.
The higher that we've got,
the high you got up until that fucking mountain that we just got fucking
stronger.
Yeah.
Dog in the winter time and all that.
There's something to that weed.
I smoked some deadly fuck a weed in Colorado,
20 years.
I don't care what anybody tells me.
If I get 28% this shit was off the fucking charts and shit that grow it.
Now,
the shit that grown out here now in a year we're going to have 45% we'd just
clean shit that you're smoking it.
Done,
done.
Do you think that there's going to be any repercussions to these states making
it illegal?
Obama said right now that they're not going to go on and after people,
but that doesn't mean anything because they said they were only going to go
after people that violated both state and federal law when he came to marijuana.
But I don't think that was necessarily the case.
I think the DEA just went after people that their operation was too big.
I think that was a lot of it.
I think that,
what do you think they're going to do here?
Between you and I?
What?
What does the federal government shut?
Shit.
Yeah,
so eventually one morning we're going to wake up,
we're going to turn it into something.
There's going to be a bunch of fucking people on the street and they're going to
raid.
You know they're going to take all the resources of one day and raid 20 fucking
stores and lock up and confiscated the big ones and hit him where it hurts and
the fucking pocket.
I know we're gonna cut out funding or something to the site.
Something's going to go down.
I don't think it needs funding.
The government is not going to have egg on their face even though that whatever
they're doing in Colorado with the marijuana,
with the medical marijuana situation is fucking beautiful.
I think in Colorado just went full like fucking legal marijuana and took that
money and tax did heavily look.
If you're gonna allow people to say so weed,
why not charge 20% taxes?
I think that's really reasonable.
Yeah,
20% taxes on everything you sell.
Let's just do that.
Then that money goes straight to the schools.
Straight to the COBB.
Straight to the teachers.
I mean that'd be honest.
How much markup is on weed as it is right now?
Imagine it being legal where everyone can girl like weeds going to be like
fucking grass.
Exactly.
I didn't give a shit mark that said like,
let us,
like you go to a supermarket,
you buy a head of lettuce for like three bucks or whatever.
You know how long it takes to grow a fucking head of lettuce.
It's amazing.
You can get one for $3,
you can get a nutritious piece of vegetable that's a long fucking time to grow
and you get up at three bucks.
That's what it would be like for wheat.
Cause those,
when you go up to Santa Barbara and you see those uh,
strawberry patches where they just go on like Ochsner,
they just go on and on and on.
That will be weed.
It will all be there.
And then they'll have to have armed guards because high school kids be sneaking
in and stealing your fucking weed.
It's not going to be [inaudible].
They probably going to be like,
Hey,
take whatever you want.
Yeah,
we got a lot of it.
I see the scar face.
We got whips the coke off the ground and the fucking licks it.
It was just on the floor.
You know what I'm saying?
Was people fucking for the people don't understand that you're going to have,
if you,
you made legal
weed and you're going to,
anytime you have people that are smoking weed,
you're going to have examples of people that are wasting their lives smoking
weed.
You're going to have those examples.
There's no doubt about it.
You're going to have kids that are lazy that just smoke weed and watch video
games and they used to be good students but they're not anymore,
but you're also going to have a lot of other people,
and this is what pisses me off the most when you see all these news reports
about weed and all this,
the problems that people are having with weed,
they don't talk about the positive benefits of it.
Just psychologically.
We all know the difference between people that we hang out with that smoke weed
and that don't smoke weed.
There's a difference and one of the differences is the people that don't smoke
weed,
there's a level of reality that they don't operate in.
You don't go there with them,
you don't have conversations with them in that level.
You don't.
There's a,
there's a place of a vulnerability in respect to the great of it all that they
don't really possess.
They have like a lens in front of them that they don't ever take out and like
raw dog.
The universe when you get really high,
it's like your raw dog in the universe.
You're getting the whole experience in and one big crazy frightening what you
call it.
Paranoia is reality.
You're,
you should be fucking paranoid and that that marijuana rush where it really
likes sets all in and like makes you really take in this experience and that
that freaky,
you know,
crazy high way.
If you,
if you're hanging out with people that don't smoke weed,
they don't go there,
then understand that talk.
They don't get that.
You can tell the difference.
I could tell that I don't judge people by that.
I really,
I know a lot of cool people that don't smoke it in a lot of great people that
don't smoke weed.
I like them for that reason.
I liked him for that reason,
but I could see where the conversation ends at.
Like,
I have a friend who has a bad back but doesn't get hot and I have been trying to
explain to him,
I understand you're,
uh,
you're,
lung concerns and stuff.
There's a fucking tablet now you could say now they have no more excuses if you
have a tight back or whatever,
they have an astro now that comes in a tablet.
It looks like a vitamin seat.
Gabba then you could travel with on a flight and they won't even fucking ask
him.
So,
and he's like,
no,
I'm scared.
I'm whatever.
Okay,
then keep going to the fucking chiropractor for the next year.
Give it a try.
I know I would if I had a fucking bad back.
I try anything if I had a fucking bad back at that point.
Yeah.
There's some people that are in fucking serious pain
and that's,
I tell you,
man,
uh,
I've heard a lot of things over the list and I'm not going to,
I get to sit here and tell you I got meant the littleness.
I got VP,
I got an itch in my ass.
I got foot fungus.
I can tell you all this shit.
They'll give anxiety,
sleep apnea.
Holy Shit.
Don't give it to you for,
I was smoking weed way before it came up from medical excuses.
I was Spanish.
Yeah.
I was smoking weed to get fucked up and see the devil planning.
Simple to see it with at the way it was every fucking day.
That's why I smoke,
but now you know.
Now it's because of the medical thing,
have the whatever,
but do I see a difference in people?
Yeah,
I understand what you're saying.
You can talk to them a little deeper.
You could actually even catch them.
Some people would all smoke weed.
You can't catch them rather than anything or even confront them on anything
because they might have a fucking heart attack.
People spoke.
We'd get to a point where you might take them somewhere and they'll giggle at
themselves.
That's what I'm saying.
There's an attitude,
but other people that can't laugh at themselves are really,
I'm going to be asked to hang out with.
You got to laugh at yourself.
Anybody who can't laugh at themselves and knowing that that's,
those are the most annoying humans.
You can't make fun of your own self at all.
You don't.
You don't think,
what do you perfect kind of Douche bag.
Are you?
What are you the Messiah,
the Motherfucker,
if that's,
you know,
one of the funniest thing about Jesus,
we were talking about people that we know that are going crazy.
Jesus lately.
One of the funny things about Jesus is that if Jesus actually really did come
back,
nobody would fucking ever believe him.
Not a chance in hell.
There's not a chance in hell if that dude wearing sandals and robes and his
beard,
just like in the pictures was walking down the street with holes in his hand and
blood coming out of his hand,
people would probably fucking arrest him.
Need to shoot him or arrest him or get him on antidepressants.
Well,
Jesus can't just show up to a party though,
Sam Jesus,
right?
Well,
but he has to do something.
He's got to do something.
He's got to do a big food.
They would say,
this is the devil.
This is the devil trying to pretend he's Jesus.
He's got a set up like Gabe,
really good gets GSP.
If it gave really gotta thank GSP down and fucking break his fucking shoulder.
That's,
you know what I'm saying?
Like something to that effect.
Something just fucking Jesus did that.
That's that ridiculous.
The salad be a miracle to be enough to convince it.
It's like Joey v is going down a one 85 and one of the fucking Olympics.
That's,
you know,
something that wouldn't even work.
You'd have to fly.
You have to come back from the data.
I mean,
think about the shit that Jesus did.
He healed the sick.
You didn't cure blind people then.
Was that one of the ones?
Yeah.
Turn water into wine though.
That was Moses would cut the ocean.
Cay can turn water into wine.
It right.
Let me ask you something about the other second year.
Did they drug test to comics?
Uh,
we've been talking about,
we were talking about the daily.
I'd say you've got a really bad comic and he kills three nights in a row.
Like comics would get together.
Commit guys on weed,
the guys on fucking something testosterone.
We better check him.
Well,
we're all on performance enhancing supplements when it comes to comedy.
Uh,
we'd,
we'd and Alpha brain together,
there's no doubt about it.
That's Goddamn performance enhancing.
Something for me loosens me and an edible to a certain degree.
Like if I eat the edible at a certain time and I'm,
I'm all wired up how he def on fucking stage,
but it comes to a point of time when I had the bowl and I just get giggly as
fuck and that you can't stop at that plan.
That's like the comfortable level.
Like not the scary s like skiing feeling when you're at like skiing through the
universe on an edible like,
oh,
I can't stop.
That's not good.
When you're stoned and it's dark at the comedy store that's right there.
When you're stoned and it's dog,
well you don't see nobody but the three people in front of you that you're
talking to stone and dark and you think you're speaking to the dark.
You're just talking into the darkness is laughter,
but you don't question it because you're fucked up.
You know what I'm saying?
And that Hollow Echo
that,
oh our man,
you want to talk about it like a historic room.
As far as like comedy rooms,
that original room,
I was like one of the most historic rooms,
like ever in the art form of comedy,
you know,
there's,
there was a weird feeling and always just being on that stage since that was
always like a like,
wow.
It doesn't matter how many years it did stand up.
When you're on stage and the original room,
you're like,
wow,
this is my,
my babies taken away because I finally figured out how I could explain the o od
to people because don't get it when you go to a gym,
the old or the gym,
the more you could smell it.
And I don't mean there's a different older to a gym.
It's like when you go to a good jujitsu school,
you could smell a little foot.
It's not overwhelming,
but you could smell just a little footnote.
Yeah.
Like you're like,
this is a good fucking gym.
It's just that perfect amount of footage.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just foot.
Well,
this is one thing that you do get from places that have a lot of experience and
that's like they have a weird vibe to him.
Like the Ice House,
like we were at the Ice House the other day after it was closed,
it was dark out and we're standing in the back.
I was like,
feel this room man,
this room has got like a crazy vibration and it sounds like total like hippy
bullshit.
That sounds like nonsense.
Like objects do not have memory.
That's what Cara Santa Maria would tell you.
There's no evidence that objects have memory,
but there's a field that places have,
whether that's a self imposed feel,
you've maybe created it and your own imagination.
But when I stand in the back room of the Ice House,
I stand there.
I just saw,
I go,
wow,
this is a crazy ass room.
Like Steve Martin motherfucker performed here.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I used to,
I watched George Lopez kill there in the 90s Carol,
when George Lopez was on fire,
like the late nineties before George Lopez at any TV shows maybe had like a few
things going on when he was just hitting it hard in the clubs every night.
I watched him destroy in that ice house,
the road he's got,
oh,
this is like a sign up there.
And when George Lopez was at his prime there where he sold out like fucking 15
shows in a row there or something crazy like that,
you know,
and I,
that place has seen some shit.
No,
but it's nothing like walking up the stairs and see original.
Nothing like making that left up those stairs.
When you're walking straight and somebody goes,
well then right or wrong,
we know what we're talking about.
Can you feel it motherfuckers,
when you first go in there and you're like,
which way?
That,
okay,
move that curtain aside.
You walk up those fucking stairs and just that older,
it smells like a little bit of booze,
a little bit like pussy,
a little bit of sweat,
bad calmly.
Good comedy,
boom.
Smells like
it just smells like success.
It's just smells like something,
something is in the air that you got to do your thing in that you really got to
do your thing in there.
And then when you sit in the back and you feel the lights would go off and on
and you'd hear that z z is the lights and you know,
it's just a weird little comedy thing you ever get to do a user hosted open
mikes there,
right.
I read that was my job.
I hosted the open mic but why was the 10 o'clock guy,
you know what's cool about that when the lights were on with all the different
people's names please.
Yeah.
You know you get to see Sam Kinison and neon.
That was one of my biggest scams of all time hosting at the comedy store.
Why is it a scam?
Because I had a perfect deal.
I would fucking go up there,
get 25 bucks to host.
I would do 2015 upfront.
I will give you a call,
Rogan a dice and tell him to come down cause I was hosting and I put you up
first.
You guys went up to the hour and I go home
and don virus or close the show and that's the way it was.
I would go up there and do his set,
bring up the fucking store.
The problem was now we uh,
when we were there all the time we were doing comedy store comedy and then when
we would go somewhere else we would bring comedy store comedy to them too.
And there was a lot of places that could not handle it.
You remember when you got fucking kicked out of Dublin's
fucking 97 or something like that.
We go and do it.
I sat at Dublin's and all of a sudden I hear yelling and whatnot.
Joey has got some chicken and ice house like a freezer,
like a giant like in room freezer and he's eating coke off her pussy and less
security comes in and tells me the fucking,
there's a camera in there and they're watching it.
That place.
Yeah,
I put the coconut,
my sock and the cops came and I'm standing in front of the fucking thing with
the CIC crying with her girlfriends.
I've never had that happen before.
And the guy with the long hair
almost died and all this shit cause he was there with them.
I see the girl in the hallway and I'm like,
what's going on and stay.
They don't want to say she's got blow lines of boats talking to say something
stupid like almost fucking killed him.
Killed you.
Walk out of here but the best or something sitting there fucking,
I got the eight ball in my soccer is,
I'm not giving that mother fuck up until the cops got that for you.
I'm old school with the cop.
Won't nothing happen.
Where's the rest of the drugs are downstairs?
Let me search.
You can't search me.
You can't fucking search me.
You have no reason.
It's his word against mine.
Where's the tape?
You know,
I wouldn't hold on to that coke,
but that's the savior.
That night was Ralphie May.
He went to the all you can eat at the Japanese fucking place across the street.
What's the name of the Japanese place?
But y'all [inaudible] y'all get exact place there anymore.
One of those fights taco now.
All right.
It's in the pink Taco.
It's a magical place.
Paint Taco that place for Vegas.
Do you know the pink Taco is place in the hard
rock in Vegas?
Good place.
They opened a Taco spot.
They're now at a Japanese Sushi place.
Yeah.
And it's a hot place to like,
it's where all the celebrities go to.
So what happened to the TACO place up to corner that's still there.
The little one on the [inaudible] $92 to get two tacos.
Bad tacos though.
Yeah,
there was a lot.
Benito's is the best.
It's Benito was good.
The ninos is fantastic and it's 24 hours.
He's out on Beverly.
Is that what it is?
We used to always go there after the Improv.
That places sensational.
That is legit.
Connie,
I sat out my friend,
extra hot sauce.
Don't play games.
Oh Shit.
Connie has sided with the all the wheel fresh,
chopped Cilantro and onions in that motherfucker and they have pickled Jalapenos
there.
Take your chances with those bitches.
Yeah.
And then throw some hot sauce on that fucker.
Two o'clock.
And by the way,
it's packed with drunks.
Packs with drugs.
You'll always find somebody you know there,
there's always somebody you know there are a victim or a victim or victor over
the miles.
Yeah.
Can we come to?
Yeah,
let me make a left on the fucking corner.
Get the fuck out of it.
Dan and I got
to it.
I will.
I mean if you have it.
Well,
but the last place I went to,
they had a bunch of cocaine.
I didn't like it.
Sure.
You don't even remember what happened.
But I got VD and I didn't even know until I gave it to join dance.
No,
I got chlamydia bitch.
Fucking differences.
I never seen the leakage out of my helmet.
I seen it out of her fucking pussy.
That's what I was saying.
How did you know you had it then?
Because I had itches at fucking burning sensation.
Temptations are fucking tube.
This should be something like that.
They sell you.
Have you made a critical error with your penis is she'd be like something you
could just slap on her.
Kills 99.999% of it.
She didn't the tube shoot it right in the hole,
right in the piss hall and then wipe it on the outside and it kills almost ever.
The foot spray says it kills 99% all,
all viruses.
And so what I did,
um,
I mean what spray you thought what I was going to do is like spray it on my Dick
and then I was in the bathroom doing it and I looked over at the mouthwash and
it's at 98% on it.
Awesome.
I'm like,
it can't be the same percent,
you know,
like that one thing,
it has to be a different,
what's the odds?
I think that one person's like aids or something.
It's probably just alcohol,
right?
Is that what's killing everything?
Yeah,
I think that number is the same.
Whether it's the mouthwash,
pray the same note as the alcohol.
I don't know what kind of foot spray brain freezes your Dick.
So you could do it from a distance.
Don't,
don't really close up cause it's right,
it comes out like freezing.
Like it's like it could freeze something.
Have you ever like I'm seeing that stuff that you use to clean off the spray
that used to clean off keyboards.
Yeah.
Same thing.
You know,
it gets really,
really cold.
That's the same thing I read somewhere that someone was addicted to that spray.
I used to do it in high school but I wasn't addicted to it.
That's the worst.
What the fuck does it do?
It,
it's just like,
you know nitrous oxide.
Like everyone did nitrogen,
the bits,
it's like that,
but it's like a shitty or version of it and it just kind of makes it,
yeah.
While,
while,
while I've worked out a Newport creamery who's an ice cream place in Newton,
Massachusetts and uh,
I never,
I think I did whip it's once but it didn't really work with me.
But,
uh,
the people that work there,
there was this one kid,
I'll just say his last name cause he knows friends,
he knows people that I know now.
His name is Charles.
I don't know if he wants this information release,
but Charles was working there as I was working there and he would,
uh,
he would tell somebody watched a grill real quick and he would run in the back
and he was cooking while I was doing dishes and he would run the back of,
grab the thing.
Yeah,
do a whip it and then run back out to it to the grill.
The best twisted out of the best.
It's got what they called nitrous hits.
What you do is you take a balloon,
you fill the balloon up with,
uh,
nitric bomb hits and you fill the,
fill the balloon up and then you put it on,
on the bong.
Somehow I remember how to do it.
So when you inhale the bong,
it's all nitrous air.
So you're getting pot air mixed with nightdress air,
hit it.
See that's all somebody only white people would come up with.
And then Snow Bong hits where you pack your bag full of snow in the wintertime.
Second through the snow.
I've seen that.
I've timed thousand ice.
I would get the fresh,
the whole pack of the bond smoke.
I love all that.
Now if I have a bong,
I put ice in it too.
Well,
we used to smoke bongs before we did the podcast,
so the problem is you get to stone.
You don't know what you're talking about,
what it's like to do.
If you're going to do bong hands and then do a podcast,
you get to take an hour or two before you talk because you're not going to
really have your fucking sea legs under you.
As Dennis Mckenna would say,
hey,
it wouldn't,
you can't,
you know bongs are too strong vaporizers,
don't you find,
don't you find vaporizers to be a different experience?
It doesn't seem to be the same.
The same experience as as just smoked.
I wouldn't get one of those vape pens at the house.
This guy had one last night that was chocolate mint chocolate and like,
all right,
these vape pens aren't the best.
Whatever.
I don't care.
I took two hits off that and it tasted so delicious.
Tastes like ice cream and I was so fucking stoned off that thing.
It was there.
Everyone has them now in La.
Everyone has like these pins that looked like little.
That's the big thing right?
That one that's going off.
Fuck people up.
That's the bottom line.
Somebody is really going to like the Eureka gets me high,
but I like at night I don't get high at night.
I won't get high and I got to switch up the tubes a lot.
Like right now I got a uh,
a sativa and I have something else.
I got a pretty good fucking sativa.
Let me ask you this,
Joe Diaz,
who if you were going to do anything with this room,
what would you suggest being done here with this new studio?
Well,
outside you got to have a mat out there.
Uh,
Jujitsu.
Absolutely.
Officer's in there,
right?
That's your office.
You know,
what's the,
what?
The way the room and you only let people come by on is a extra room.
It ain't no fucking makes no,
no extra beat.
We had a couple people here the other day.
Dennis brought a positive,
well,
Russell Peters comes here.
You're going to need that just for him.
Just for his ego.
Oh,
can you put the pool test kit?
Right,
so definitely have a mat up here.
A lot of people were mad at Russell Peters because of that.
A mix master Mike Interview.
I thought he added a lot to it and add a lot of Dj knowledge,
you know,
to talk.
Tell us a lot of shit about needles.
Why people such haters.
I talked to him about it a couple of days ago and what did he say?
He was bummed about it because you know you've got,
Twitter is so harsh,
you know when it ends.
It's just a bunch of mean cons.
I mean most people like why not just listen to it and just take it in?
He was a goddamn three hour conversation.
Mike told a lot of shit about working with the Beastie boys to a lot of shit
about Dj and being in front of it.
He said he was in front of 400,000 fucking people.
400,000 people in Germany by the way.
His CD's out,
free CD's out.
Where do you get it?
Uh,
I think it's mix master mike.com mix master mike.com.
I believe the eyes are all ones.
I think it's one of those he's,
he's uh,
he's leaked.
You remember that back in the uh,
the video game days.
He'd be leaked out.
I think it's one,
but uh,
his websites and mix master mike.com using the regular spelling and it's a free
CD and it's really good.
It's a remix city and he's cool as fuck.
It was a awesome having him on the podcast.
Even if Russell Peters did fuck up the interview.
You did.
You didn't.
Russell's a sweetie.
I don't know how anybody could not like Russel,
you're bipolar.
No,
I'm just,
just jokes.
So Polo Russell fucking,
Peter's a nice kid.
He's,
he's a,
he's a great guy and takes great Goodman.
They have a lot of good friends and he does good for kids.
You know,
when I like,
I like when a guy hits big,
like he does and becomes more generous.
That's what he,
that's how he is.
He's something he did,
I didn't know about.
I found out the other day,
like when Sam there was an HBO special and uh,
they originally wanted to have,
or they originally wanted to have Sam on the HBO special or the Comedy Central
Special.
But then at the last second they're like,
all right,
we're not gonna,
we don't have enough money for you Sam to pave for you and to film it and all
that stuff so we're not going to have you on the on the special.
So Russell paid out of his own pocket,
like paid for them to film it and put it on the special.
And I really like pumped up Sam AAA like five years ago or so.
They're totally sounds like something he would do.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a perfect example of a guy who's got a lot of great things that are
happening for him.
Like if you see,
Russell was showing me pictures of his on his phone,
he's doing like 15,000 seat arenas and he's doing them on a regular basis and
he's a perfect example of a guy who's just a fucking sweetheart of a guy and
people go to see them,
they have a great experience and they tell more people about them and then they
come and him more and then it's
he,
he's got swarms of people and it all happened by the way,
because they liked his stuff.
This didn't happen because he was on so fucking crazy sit-com it didn't happen
because he was in a great movie.
It happened because he had youtube clips,
people saw the youtube clips and then this guy is awesome and then it all grew
from there.
It's up to,
he has like,
he's as one of the,
Russell Peters is one of the best Internet success stories ever.
Really does as far as like us as far as like comics that have gone from just
putting out a video and then making it huge and big places.
Russell's the fucking man and he's a sweetheart.
I,
I've hung out with that guy in Vegas so many times.
He came in his fucking watch gave it to me.
See this watch,
this is like a really nice watch is a Breitling and I,
all I did is I said we were at a bar.
You were there.
I got,
hey man,
it's like a $10,000 watch,
right?
Or something crazy.
I don't know what it costs,
but it's,
it's,
it's traded watches.
Alicia,
he threw a year,
watch away the next day,
cause that smells my lunch.
I would wear to the gym.
Sorry.
Instead of leather band on it.
I'd been lifting weights with that watch.
You should've kept it.
It smelled,
it attracted like powerful females.
Yeah.
He um,
I've looked at his watch and I go,
that's cool.
Watch man.
Just like that.
I just go,
that's a cool watch.
And he goes,
here,
it's yours.
And I go get the fuck Outta here man.
He's like,
take it,
tag it,
grabs my hand,
sticks it over.
My hand is ridiculous.
Or buck angel,
it would attract buck angel.
You should probably check my watch.
Would trek can show how much you want for the Wad.
That was a Jeremy that,
that's the last piece to my puzzle.
If I put that watch on,
I know I'll be fucking manly and wonder if like girls who become boys still
stink like dudes do.
You know,
cause dude to put out a certain fucking stinky dudes put out like a certain odor
that you don't get from stinky chicks.
You know,
like in your,
in the line at the airport when you're going through security.
So you're forced to be like really close to people and you get a whiff of a
motherfucker.
It's very rarely a girl.
It's almost always a dude.
There's always a dude we like,
whoa.
This mother fucker's stinks that like heavy,
rotten under smell.
Apparently.
I found the answer to our question earlier about,
uh,
underarms and what it was,
women's started shaving their legs and it was like the 1940s are like 1915.
Rather.
There was a,
uh,
a campaign for women to shave their under harm hair.
Cause before nine 1915 women didn't shave their underarm hair.
They all went straight Madonna and there was this disdain.
They were brow beaten into this in 1915 apparently I would like to,
um,
I,
I would like to find out what the,
uh,
what the campaigns look like.
But it was in Harper's bizarre,
a magazine aimed at the upper crust,
the first ad feature,
the waist up photograph of a young woman who appears to be dressed in a slip
with a Toga like outfit covering one shoulder.
Her arms are arched over her head,
revealing perfectly clear armpits.
The first part of the ad read summer dress and modern dancing combined to make
necessary the removal above jection double hair.
So that's what it is.
They just showed some women some unrealistic vision,
much like we have seen in our lifetime with pussy,
like we were talking about earlier when I was a kid of girl would pour pants
down and you got what you got,
you got welcome to the jungle,
you got fucking craziness.
We didn't do anything with our cubes.
They didn't do anything with theirs.
And if a girl did shave her pussy,
all my God,
it was like chaos.
I had a girl that broke up with her boyfriend.
Okay.
And then we got back together again and we couldn't have sex.
She goes,
we can't,
we can't have sex.
I go by,
she goes,
we can't.
I go,
why?
What's wrong?
She goes,
I shaped myself down there for him.
She was embarrassed that her pussy.
I hadn't grown back yet.
So I was like,
it's alright.
It's not,
it's no big deal.
You just don't have any pussy hair.
Come on.
But I don't know the had sex with this guy.
Settle the fuck down.
I can do too.
I can do the math.
You're shit.
She was ashamed.
She was ashamed that she shaved off her pussy hair for this guy.
Isn't that hilarious?
She couldn't just say,
yeah,
that's my new thing.
You know,
fuck,
fuck pussy hair.
No,
it was dirty.
It was dirty for her.
Like she had done a dirty,
dirty thing.
She shaved her pussy.
You know what I did for him?
What?
I shaved my,
he doesn't know your dad shut up.
Let me see if I have a talk to you.
They would get pulled your underwear down and then that girl would go
immediately until all of her friends.
That dirty bitch.
It's shaving her pussy.
Shut the fuck up.
Give me a sec.
All right.
I need a cigarette right now.
I can't believe this.
Oh my God.
That whore,
that whore is shaving that pussy.
All these checks in Boston would sit around smoking cigarettes.
Talk Shit about if you should have shaved your pussy.
They found out that fucking whole,
Ah,
why not just put a sign and say come fuck me,
Eh,
anti arm hair adds began appearing in middlebrow McCall's in 1917 women's razors
and depilatory.
What's depilatory I that like pulls it out from the roots.
Right?
Those are those,
those horrible ones.
You ever seen those things?
They look like fucking strings and they just wrap around your armpit hair and
yanked him out of the roots.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Well that's okay.
That's very good.
That's very,
eh,
it's uncomfortable.
That's uncomfortable.
Woo.
The soundbite.
I do this to lean.
So Instagram a,
the president of Instagram,
please tell me this.
Originally what happened is this,
a Instagram supposedly had how have these new rules out saying and in the roles,
it was a deciphered that Instagram has,
can sell your photos to a third party.
So say like you're an advertising company and it's like,
Hey,
I want to buy some photos of girls kissing balloons and they so that you could
go in there and just,
they could just buy your photos and make money off your photos.
Meaning they can turn a profit on your,
so you might be to go to like a store one day to buy mountain dew and there's a
picture of you laughing with a mountain,
you and your hands you put on your Instagram.
But Instagram just like as within like the next last couple hours like the co
owner or president or something like that said that this is not the case.
This is just uh,
you know,
people are,
are taking this wrong.
We are not starting to photos,
you own the photos,
blah blah blah.
But you know,
that's seems kind of weird.
Like how,
why is it written down that way?
So it,
unless they turn,
take a,
uh,
you know,
they changed the terms.
Uh,
there's still some question there and I guess there's more developing about it.
So it should be,
we'll figure it out soon.
But do you have till January 16th where this new term kicks in?
So if you delete your account supposedly in all your photos by that time then
that they won't have the photos.
So probably some mad backlash.
That's what that problem.
Yeah,
it looks like it.
They got caught pretty much.
And,
but Instagram is now owned by Facebook and Facebook also is going through the
same kind of shit right now,
you know,
with this whole like did they own your property?
Can they,
you know,
well,
I think it's really important.
I mean,
if there's anything that,
uh,
any like function that groups like anonymous serve,
you know,
that it's really important.
It's not just like political and governmental stuff,
but shit like this to keep companies on their toes,
like hackers,
like just the threat of someone realizing that there's an imbalance and wanting
to correct it.
You know that these really intelligent kids that are like you were in Russia and
shit from all sorts of places where you can't get them through a hundred
proxies,
they will come down on you men,
they will come fuck you.
And you know,
I think Instagram probably recognize that.
I hope that's not what it was.
I hope that they really was a misunderstanding in the first place.
You never want to hear that a company is thinking about selling all your fucking
picture.
Oh.
You also have to think that a lot of times that this happens all the time.
You sign up for a website,
you know,
and you upload something to their computers.
They actually do pretty much own that.
You know,
it's,
if you look at it as basic as if uh,
you have your own website and,
and it's a computer,
you know,
hooked up at your house and you have your website on that computer and then
somebody is putting files on your computer that's like,
you know,
a real basic version of what a Facebook is.
It's a,
they own all these computers.
You're putting your information and your stuff.
And you're putting it on their computer.
They do pretty much own it.
If they went out of business tomorrow,
just turned off the lights,
they could take all those computers and look at all your pictures and own you.
They own your pictures.
But I think the real issue in this country,
money try to sell it,
but it's,
it's the idea that you,
you also don't really think like shit.
Every single text that I do back and forth between people on Facebook or any
photo that I have hidden my inbox or anything that got private that,
you know,
no one can see except me.
All that can be seen by somebody and somebody can own that and take that.
So if you,
you know,
ever say or do anything,
they pretty much get to do whatever the fuck they want with it except sell it,
I guess is the big thing.
Yeah.
I think the big thing though is the sell it,
especially the using it for advertising.
So as long as they're not going to do that,
they will,
they will escape the wrath of the fucking legion.
Yeah.
But what if it's something like,
you know how like how this guy is talking today about like,
you know,
we are not going to sell your stuff.
You know,
what if he's just also saying that,
you know,
like a backlash thing,
but in a way of like,
yeah,
we're not going to sell it.
We're going to get money to,
to sponsor a company and then we're just going to give them your photos,
you know,
or something.
You know what I mean?
Like there they're doing some kind of backs snaggle way where they're,
you know,
they're getting paid for it but just it not directly,
if that's possible.
But I think you also have to think of like,
okay,
what is this service worth and why am I getting it for free?
What am I giving them?
I'm giving them a bunch of users.
Well,
a bunch of users ain't worth shit unless you can get something out of it.
So what is it worth?
Is it worth that they put a little ad in the corner of your picture when people
go to look,
I mean like what is the,
where's the line that you draw?
Because we're basically getting this free service where we get to upload these
photos.
And one of the things that you and I know about from doing this podcast is that
bandwidth costs a lot of fucking money.
If you're,
if you're like,
if you're,
you know,
a company like Instagram,
they must be dealing in insane gigabytes to run their servers.
But that's why you don't understand how Instagram even became big.
I know it's the filter thing.
Everyone wants to see the filters and like,
oh,
that's like,
filters are so big right now.
That's what it is.
It's girls pretending to look different than they look.
But they didn't have superior companies like flicker who I've been using for a
long time.
Uh,
where you pay a little bit,
I think it's like 40 bucks a year,
but you own everything.
You don't have to worry about this Instagram shit like that.
And you know,
when it comes to filters,
half the apps that you have on your phone just make filters and you just send it
to flicker.
You,
the thing about Instagram though is it became,
um,
a phone thing,
whereas flicker was like a computer thing.
Instagram became a way of peep for people like to communicate like Twitter
style,
Twitter picture.
Right.
But I don't know why it became an entity on its own.
Like why didn't they just use twit pic builtin Twitter?
It's because of the filters.
I think it's just the APP.
Yeah,
those tricky bitches.
They want to look like Magenta hued to look like they're living in a dream.
And there's only like what,
eight different filters in that you get.
You get like a APP that I like.
There's one called a hundred cameras,
you know,
where it has a hundred different apps,
uh,
filters,
you know,
and it's like 99 cents and it just sends it to your Twitter,
your Twitter,
your twit pic or whatever.
Yeah,
there's a bunch of them like that,
right?
That like connect with it.
Yeah.
It's probably better than Instagram,
but I've got like 50,000 fucking people on my instruments.
The profit at this point in time.
How many of those are not on my Twitter?
Like I can't abandon them.
Everybody in a bandage it because of this new policy.
So if it stays how it originally was,
where they do get to do whatever the fuck they went to and they will,
uh,
I probably will delete my account cause I only went on Instagram because
everyone told me to.
And it's like,
oh,
it's so popular.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I don't get it.
You know,
can use twit pic,
you
know,
remember every last told me I have to use it.
Yeah.
Came in and said that people been in a man.
Do you don't use your Instagram was really what's wrong,
a tweeter down.
That's about it.
Yeah.
But you know what's going on now for whatever fucking reason.
Even though I've updated it,
my iPhone does not want to connect with the fucking Instagram.
My iPhone is not interested in sending pictures through Instagram smart.
He knew this whole fucking thing was going to happen.
He's just good doing good.
I got a new iPhone and it's like,
fuck you bitch.
Fuck.
Every time I tried to send pictures through Iphone,
I was trying to spend this Instagram photo because I took a photo of Brad Pitt
with Chanel number five.
Brad Pitt's got to fucking men's Cologne commercial looking at,
I don't know,
but I was trying to put on Twitter or on Instagram that if you buy this stinky
shit,
I hope nobody fucks you for the rest of your life.
I was trying to put that out,
which I thought it'd be nice and witty on my way home from the airport and uh,
your anticline and all the way.
It's fucking gross,
man.
I did one little spray of Timberlake before I leave every day.
That's confused as well.
Animal.
No,
I don't trust the eyes.
If I smell Colona the guy,
but I put my lake and he gets a good smell.
Timberlake.
The fucking sentence.
You probably can't even smell it.
Smelled a little bit.
I don't want to smell nobody.
Trust me.
I'll fucking fart right on your legs.
Don't come over here and fuck.
I don't want small,
local,
whatever.
Yeah,
whatever your stinking of.
He just not the of on don't do it.
I told him I can't tell him do a Joey,
don't do it.
Don't let them,
don't let him should go away.
Cock suck.
I suck.
I'll stab you with this coffee.
Pick it.
Was that Mitzi?
Who are you doing?
Joey D is,
I'll,
I'll tweet you guys this picture later after the show.
One of the problems that might be one of his last time you reset your phone.
I noticed it.
Yeah,
I did everything.
I disconnected.
I deleted Twitter.
I deleted Instagram.
I reinstalled both of them.
It won't work.
Uh,
have you put in your password lately on Instagram?
Maybe hiring a wrong password?
No.
It's all right.
Everything's right.
It's just not,
won't,
won't reach the server logs on the Instagram won't reach server.
Some,
some wacky bullshit.
Are you in the Verizon network?
You know what it is?
It's,
it understands that I like my Samsung Galaxy s three a little bit better.
My Samsung Galaxy s three from ting mobile.
I like it a little better.
Really?
Like this wacky fucking phone.
How about that?
Huh?
That's crazy.
Talk.
Crazy talk.
But you'll like your iPhone dog.
I liked the Samsung Galaxy s three better.
I think that fucking big screen.
And how's that camera compare that fat ass.
Oh,
you like the Samsung.
You can't,
they're both awesome.
The Samsung Galaxy s three as I fucking iPhone cameras.
You'd see the showtime special.
You know what else it does?
You know what else?
Yes sir.
He does.
I can take a burst of photos.
You could jump up in the air and I'll take a burst of photos up and down.
It tastes like a ship.
This is on the Verizon network.
Correct.
Um,
I think you can get it on Verizon.
I know you can get it on sprints cause we have it on [inaudible],
which is on sprint and I know you can get it on 18 t two.
It's a fucking wicked.
Those big screens are wicked and it's good.
And like everything else it doesn't,
it's good enough.
How much shit do you need?
How many apps do you need,
goddammit?
Except blades.
Linear from kerosene games coming out in January on the android application.
I listened to a some Pablo Francisco and the other day.
What are you doing with this Brad Picker Marshall?
You really plan a Brad Pitt commercial.
You fuck.
It's not a journey.
Every journey ends,
but we go on.
I'd let them fuck me.
Twirled turns when we turn with it.
What's your too deep?
Deep Man's disappear put in my mouth.
Dreams takeover.
Oh,
but wherever I go,
oh,
there you are.
I bet his kisses.
Salty luck.
My fate,
my porch.
Chanel number five.
Whoa.
No you didn't.
Brad.
Brad,
Brad does not enough money in the world for that.
who's your fucking agent?
You could have caught it off before you said Chanel number five.
You would have been okay.
You would've been okay as long as you mention her name.
What gave you the fucking,
they'll eat a beet and comes this shit on number five.
No,
no,
no.
He has to end it and let someone else like Morgan Freeman.
So you should nail number five.
Someone else says the Chanel number five.
Someone unrelated to that.
Really Corny fucking snitch.
Every walk ends,
but we go on
the stick flies and we chase after it.
Training disappears.
Instincts take over.
Do not change the channel,
but wherever I fetch,
there you are.
My Wag,
my tree,
my belly rub,
Ken l number five
that's a joke.
When I was a junk one.
Meanwhile,
by the way,
less opportunities,
less pretentious than the Brad Pitt one.
It was resident.
I would rather the lots of the Brad Pitt one,
and let's examine this because this is one of the most preposterous commercials
I've seen since the baby just for men commercial where the baby drives a
Porsche.
Every journey ends,
but we go on,
the world turns when we turn with him,
plans disappear.
Dreams take over.
But wherever I go there you are
luck.
My fate,
my fortune.
Chanel number five
I get the habitable.
I guess there's more of them were saying,
we got to find more of them because I'll never listen to award.
That motherfucker says ever again.
Unless they gave all that money to pregnant babies in Africa.
Unless all a hundred percent of that money went to the pregnant babies.
Right?
What's that?
What is it?
Fuck with Brad Pitt,
they thought,
you know,
just that commercial.
I just saw the picture of him was Chanel number five and I just was going to
tweet something silly about it,
but I didn't know that there was a whole goddamn advertising campaign that has
the most preposterous ads ever.
Here we go,
but we go on please.
Hold on.
It's not a journey.
Every journey.
That's the same thing.
Go on.
We'll turn to return.
Was it plans disappear,
dreams Chicco
wherever I go.
There you are.
My say,
my fortune
Chanel number five is none.
Stop.
There's nothing that pussy in the world.
Give me the talk like that ever.
I just want you to know there's not enough money and just not that you couldn't,
you couldn't stack it high enough.
I'd be like,
stop it.
I can't say that.
That's why it doesn't make any sense.
This is the chick from Avatar.
They got out of the basement.
She's got us.
They just brought her over.
Ain't gonna suck is the big blue crazy Dee.
She's gonna suck his fucking yank tonight.
What are you fucking nuts?
Wherever I go,
they were all turns.
We turn with it,
right?
What have mill.
Why did you write that down?
Why did you even write that down in the world?
No,
the guy who wrote it,
the world terminals and you turn with it.
What?
Come on,
stop it.
You breathe in,
you breathe out,
your step left.
Who Step right?
You open the door,
then you shut it.
You get in your car,
you drive.
Then you hit the brakes.
Like what fucking rope is that?
It's like some of the most preposterous silly.
Yeah.
Horse Shit.
And it's not coming out of it.
Struggling actor.
Okay.
If you're a struggling actor and you know,
and someone comes up to you and they give you a break and it's to do this crazy
corny Chanel number five commercial,
that wasn't a struggling actor.
That's a motherfucking multimillionaire.
We need to find out where that money went.
It might go to pregnant babies.
If it goes to pregnant,
starving babies with aids.
We'll let him slide.
Pay The fucking village off by a village.
I wonder.
I just asked you.
We think you'd go for that.
You'd have to give him like something like that right here.
Goddamn Brad Pitt.
He's gotta get me a fee.
If it was Brad Pitt's agent,
I mean,
he's Brad motherfucking pit holes that he has big commercials overseas.
Like,
Oh yes.
We do them in big Pan and she had a lot of them.
Shit.
That's why a lot of American celebrities feel like you can't,
you're not supposed to do a commercial because if you do commercial like uh,
you know,
if you like,
if you're a movie star,
well you watch him.
What is this red tape?
Japanese commercial
pushing a car.
He's dressed up like a goofball.
He's dressed up weird like Jim style on this Horse Dung moving like Charlie
Chaplin.
See that's fine.
That's just him moving around and taking a picture.
I don't have any problem with that.
I've got a problem.
When you're staring at the camera,
talking about the world turns and you turn away.
I touched my tongue TRS
balance
that they say,
Joey Diaz,
fuck big pussy in Japan.
See these are great because he's not talking in English.
He doesn't say anything.
He's just playing a character.
These might as well be.
I mean he might as well be in a movie.
Look,
he,
I mean he's a very clever about the way he did this.
Like the first one.
He's clearly acting,
he's got a weird,
crazy,
cooky yellow outfit on and in this one he's,
he's,
he's playing a role and he's pretending to pick this giant fucking sumo guy up.
That shit is impossible.
I want you to know,
because Joey Diaz is not as big as that guy,
but I'm probably stronger than Brad Pitt and I tried to pick up
Joey up once when he was seated and it was no dice.
I went double under hooks on Joey's back.
I got a gable grip.
It wasn't happening man.
Even though the big guy from the US from pride couldn't pick me up over his
head.
Really?
Bob Sapp upside one of the most uncomfortable things for everybody.
How high did it get you up there?
If he was having a heart,
I was really like top heavy or something.
I was fine,
but Bob was never,
for years people would put computers on me or what not.
Cell phones,
all that stuff,
and my friend said,
listen,
go to godaddy.com I went over to go daddy.com I didn't know about computers.
I know about social networks.
I knew nothing.
I went to go daddy.
They had a web builder,
one,
two,
three boom.
Step by step that with your right the way once you do it,
within minutes,
your web pages up.
I didn't have that online presence.
People that had a call here like it was still 1969 but ever since I got to go
daddy or get pay pal.
I take visa online.
They got the open table,
not to mention my Yelp reviews and great Frank's pizza is number one.
Go to Frank's the services exceptional.
Frank's delivery system is always on time and the pizza's always warm.
If you want to build your empire like me,
start with go daddy.com go daddy.
What's happening?
Nothing.
I'm just calling you to see what's cracking.
I have a good day.
Okay,
that's beautiful.
I fucker.
That's how much of that did you write?
80% of it come on dog and you have no idea what you're talking about.
They just give you like a rough thing doctor that morning.
Do
you know the points for this thing?
I'm like,
well no,
I didn't get the thing and they go,
these are good points.
You got to say,
and it was in between like shooting like it was in between shooting Mike's
Inbetween like they came old already.
Right.
Let's pick it up from the other thing.
I had to go back and pick up pay pal,
pickup that the tanning booth like that.
Man,
that was fucking crazy that morning.
I was quite,
yeah,
that seems like that's a,
that's a great utilization of you like let,
yeah,
just give me a given the points and let them rant a little bit.
Why fuck around and curse Brad Pitt doesn't have to say breathe in,
breathe in,
breathe out the world saying you turn away.
That's the first time I ever saw Brad Pitt in the commercial or am I
hallucinating?
No,
that's a,
I think he's sold his soul down the river.
I think.
Uh,
how many kids you got kids,
she's got a lot of houses and he spent on a lot of shit movies lately and
Angelina has been pulling all the weight.
And when's the last time Brad was in a big head?
Moneyball was that big yet wasn't the baseball movie.
I didn't see that.
Okay.
So I'm wrong.
So how much money you think you made from that enough to,
for 80 kids and type point you just to talk to him.
20 cause what they get from movie got to give him 20 just to talk.
Maybe that's not enough.
The way they're balling and fucking,
you know Gucci clothes for little babies and shit.
20 million.
The movie he does three,
that's 60.
She does the same.
That's a buck 20 kind of ease.
That's,
that's some fucking cash dog fucking,
I wonder how much they've given him for the movies.
20 I worked for him rather for uh,
these commercials for fuck cause that whole campaign he said,
let's shoot five or six little call.
If he got together with his silly black and white commercial and they overlapped
it with Stephen Dorff,
silly black and white commercial items.
They just spliced it back and forth.
You went from one douchey statement to the other.
I think that would be,
listen,
mischief maker,
we know you're out there.
We're calling you were,
we're setting the freak flag up over the rug and compound.
We need you to put together the possibly do.
She has commercials of all time together with kiss the song kissing me in the
background.
Yes,
those man.
We don't want to fuck with your artistic integrity by giving you a suggestion
that you haven't.
But Brandon,
you know what?
You know what to do,
you know,
to do the right thing.
Go Man,
this fucking guy was very good money.
I bet he's a great actor.
He was great in an interview with a vampire.
I loved them and that I loved them in a lot of moves,
grades in the fight clubs.
But I just bullshitting.
But I just wish he didn't do that fucking commercial.
I mean,
that's just seems like so Horesh you know I should talk.
I did fear factor for six years.
Then I went back and did it again.
But even I wouldn't do that shit.
Hell commercial.
Sure.
You what?
I think point
Joe rode off.
No Fi ring.
You should smell really stinky.
This is the new UFC Chandela dish.
First of all,
I could never do it because it's been widely,
I've said it a hundred times in the podcast that I hate all that stuff.
I don't like any form of Cologne.
I wear deodorant because if I don't,
I smell really,
I smell like meat,
Sicilian,
old meat.
You smells as silly.
My underarms,
I want to shave my under
a Rugala plus you know what folks I get through life,
I exude a lot of energy.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't half ass things so I'm,
I'm putting forth effort all day.
And when you putting forth effort,
oh shake comes out grinding,
sweating and shit is going down inside your body and when it comes out of your
armpits it smells horrible.
So I'll wear a little deodorant.
So if you smell me and you're like,
what a hypocrite.
It's wearing some fucking clothes.
I'm not,
that's just old spice.
That's what I prefer.
Old Spice Sport.
Not antiperspirant cause I'm not trying to stop sweating.
I like sweating a little bullshit.
You sweat a little baby CK one,
whatever the fuck it is.
Just in case I got reframes me and I got a suit on or something.
And that other one,
you know,
I'll put a little dab on my neck.
What is this one?
What does this commercial with the fuck is going on here?
Right.
Big Brother's about to show you that same Christmas.
Oh this is the thing that you did with Dean Cain.
This is the latest,
this is the one for this year called that the dog was saved.
The holidays.
Very balance on
Shelley long.
Joey Lawrence.
Oh,
that's me as Zeus.
You need a little backup on this one.
Top
top bill on this?
Yeah.
What is that?
You can't even get top billing or Shelley long.
You fucking believe this shit.
What the fuck?
This fucking day and age is like respect.
Did you get billing at all?
Did they even mention your names?
My fucking,
yeah,
I get like they treat me like a fucking Puerto Rico in this sport.
But did you like working with Dean Cain?
Yeah,
I did like five,
five foot fucking movies.
Five of those days hanging out with Michael Gross and my last Joey Lawrence or
no,
I didn't bother nobody.
Michael Gross is one of those guys as it had been a bunch of movies and he's a
really good actor like you.
And then you see him in that and you go,
oh that's what that guy's name is.
I seen that guy in a bunch of things that guys good.
How many times you know what I watched today,
man?
I started recording it here on the studio.
Some Walker,
Texas ranger.
Oh my goodness.
It's fucking good.
Cause it's so funny.
I want to,
I want to play a little bit of it for you cause it's so ridiculous.
I recorded on the Dvr,
I forgot how good that show is.
That show is like,
might as well be a comic book that was written in 1950 you know what I mean?
When he walk up on paying everything,
oh it's this side kick was a red,
this leak.
Is it a fight?
He gets in a fight in this bad guy's office and the t two bad guys,
henchmen tried to close in on him and he's strong.
He's in a little crow's environment,
but he's strong like mad karate kicks and shed talking to her,
don't play games,
throw a wheel kicks and shit is,
and we read off the badge,
throws wheel kicks with cowboy boots on.
Shit.
Anyway,
knock this guy out and then goes up to him,
grabs him,
you know,
and it starts questioning them and the acting that came out of this meathead
that was lying down on the ground.
It might be the worst is acting ever recorded on Phelan put on salvation.
I it's,
it's beautiful.
It's a great show.
Those shows,
like you watch those shows and you wonder what they were really going to read
bag fortunately.
Why?
What's going on it jelly.
What's the show?
What's your character's name in that?
Nickelodeon.
So Joey Lasagna.
What do you pull it off?
Meatballs.
Joey meatballs.
Totally beat the beat.
Bulking meatball king.
It's so funny seeing Joey now out in public and like people come up like,
can you sign this for my daughter?
And you're like,
what the fuck is that?
And then you realize that he's known for this character called Joey meatballs.
What shows us king cake of it.
Yeah.
Kicking what is kicking it?
It's a show on Disney XD now.
What if these people ever see you on stage or listen to one of these fucking
podcasts?
Yes.
No,
no.
The funny thing is that these kick in,
it's
the funny thing is that all these shows to advertise them that put on there by
the networks.
Nickelodeon knows that if they gonna pull out a trailer and the commercial,
it's a lot cheaper to put the trailer on Youtube.
Right.
Kids will know that they come up and they'll hit it.
Yeah.
There's thousands of hits on these trailers for kicking it,
right?
You go on to the trailer,
the how mom and you got to see what it says.
If you ain't hide right,
two o'clock,
I'll fuck your mother Lucy.
Slow Bush.
I want to eat your pussy and Queloz.
You got to see like
one for like,
uh,
pull up the comments.
Brian,
what is this word?
That's why you came to your center.
This is where my money.
What is this?
You got Mike Go.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
You'd be making a delivery.
I'm done with the library,
but don't take a job with you.
I didn't know what kind of person you were,
but I do now.
What are you doing here with?
Go for it.
He's got lots of breaks.
You might even know him.
Stop before I get retarded.
That might turn me down.
That's worse.
The Walker,
Texas Ranger.
Listen,
we're going to have to compare.
We're going to have to compare that to Walker,
Texas ranger because I'm telling you pretty damn quick.
One second.
Yeah,
that was nice.
That was not good.
Can you imagine if
he was really fighting with these kids?
You know,
you know what the worst thing is when you first come to Hollywood and you meet
somebody like that,
that somebody that's been in one of these really horrible shows and they make
you watch it all the time,
they're real and you try to go to their house.
Have you ever had that happen?
Oh please.
Oh,
it's the worst.
When people email.
You should still,
I still get shit on Facebook and Twitter.
Watched my reel and tell me what you think.
Why would you ask a guy like me at five in the morning?
It was fucking stolen.
Okay.
That beanie,
that Diana Red Beanie.
You going back to Columbus for the holidays?
No,
but I'm going back in March,
uh,
with Joe Rogan and look at this shit.
Are you turn around and look at this Tara,
we can't show this on TV cause we don't have the rights for it.
It's chuck,
Doris just,
I mean it's like,
it's hilarious.
Doe Watch this one dude though.
This is my favorite.
After he smashes this guy and then the big guy grabs him.
Now Watch this move.
Kickoff the wall.
Boom.
Throw him down.
Now check this Anderson Silva like elbow.
Now Watch this acting.
This is the worst acting ever.
This girl,
I told the other guys what guys give their names.
Chuck is excellent.
How bad is the goon?
And he's just out.
He's just out again.
And then there's some kids that he has to hug.
That's what he does.
Saves your world and hugs.
Who Kids fucking shows.
Great.
Especially when you're as high as the national deficit.
Let me tell you something.
The other day I was cleaning up my fucking room and I found a package for 18
wheels of justice.
No show,
right?
The first show I ever shot.
That wasn't Lorenzo Lamas,
right?
So one of those fucking actors down and whatever,
I forgot all about it.
18 wheels of justice was the first booking of him before I wanted to tell me the
ladies a fucking old lady,
she'll torture you.
You I want in their book the book he role where I had a smack,
a fucking a playmate in the ass and she walks out of the room,
18 wheels of justice.
It was in 2000 I shot one of those episodes in San Diego on them and they gave
me 60 bucks for per diem.
Oh my God.
I didn't eat nothing.
I saved it.
The dual grammar blow.
It wasn't uh,
Lorenzo.
No,
with some other news.
Oh my God.
See what else he's shot.
Suzanne lucky the news.
He's fucking working in the Tampa revival group right down reviving fucking
Godspell.
This guy was the head guy in the show and they don't even have a photo of him.
I am DV.
Is this it?
G Gordon Liddy man.
It's how they grew up in a house.
Yeah,
that's it.
Oh God.
That was the guy
and he was like trying to like,
that was guys what spike,
which was 10 ed at the time.
Oh that's right.
It was the national,
that was what they tried to do.
Original programming.
That was it.
That was hard.
Yup.
That's a good idea.
I have a show called the national network and you're like,
listen,
this is what we got.
We got a lot of truckers,
a lot of truckers watch.
How about a trucker superhero?
How about truck or superhero that had just an ordinary guys just backed into
extraordinary circumstances and uh,
he's forced to,
you know,
man up and pulled himself up by his bootstraps and become a reluctant hero.
I mean,
I think it's basically Bj and the bear,
but no chimp,
one of the,
one of the best shows of all time Bj and the bear.
Remember back when Bj and the bear was on and we thought champs were like these
little cute things that you could hug before they started eating people's faces
and fighting.
It ticks off and shit.
And he never heard about that when our kids never heard about a champ bite and
people's faces off.
[inaudible]
that's the fucking problem.
Well,
it wasn't that one that one lady that lived in Connecticut that had the pet
chimp,
she was feeding that fucking champ.
Xanax.
She's feeding it Xanax and was drinking wine.
Yeah,
the bitch was taken Xanax so she would leave.
The chimp wants is asked to give him a fucking Xanex.
Give me a Xanax.
He's going to eat your face.
Give him a fucking sonics.
That probably is why eight,
that chick's face,
he was probably coming down from xanaxes
is all Zadie out red bag,
pork champ between an edible did HIV something.
I don't know why he kicked in about 10 minutes ago.
He hit the wall.
Why do we call it the Eddie Bravo post one hour wall?
What?
Why?
What have I hit?
No fucking wall.
Eddie probably goes guns blazing for the first hour of podcast and then,
and then like an hour and he goes,
so what,
anything.
No,
you fucking guys.
I'm looking,
I don't know.
He's Rambo town is striking.
Any Eddie Bravo Ladies and gentlemen for Eddie Bravo fans,
which of course we all are Eddie Bravo,
fens and he's the shit.
He's got his own podcast and he just started doing called Eddie Bravo radio and
a,
if you are down with chem trails,
that is the podcast for you.
If you want to hear more about Phillip Corso and Ufos and Jujitsu and MMA and
crop circles and chem trails and music and music.
This fuck powerful kiss knowledge,
Bravo.
And uh,
he does it with all their,
and Zack and rob.
All these guys that we trained Jujitsu with.
I don't know if he's going to do it with them every episode or if he's just
doing it like that for now.
But Eddie Bravo radio if you're down and if you're not,
don't get cunty cherry.
Kay.
So the fuck down.
That's my brother.
Do you remember this website?
Joey d?
Yes I do.
Yay.
I'm Joe.
It is here way back machine.
What did you find that those,
look,
you've got to icehouse banner.
No,
that you don't come and want to see what,
there was a chicken there that sent me a message on me.
I want to see if it's still on that Hoopa.
Don't,
don't show it online.
Is that online still this thing and the Internet archives.
So they look,
here's the picture of Pablo from back in the day that you probably forgot about.
That's what I was just saying,
that it was listening to Pablo on the way over here.
Um,
they had,
uh,
it was on the Jamie Foxx is a thing.
The foxhole,
it's the same one where he's interviewing Quentin Tarantino and uh,
I was listening to a Pablo and Pablo is so fucking entertaining that do,
did nothing but Jackie Chan like elect Jackie Chan like trailer like jokes,
you know,
like he's the nicest guy in the world,
like I'm so nice.
Why you have to fight me?
And it was,
he just did nothing but dad for 10 minutes and I'm just laughing like,
like a fool in my car,
giggling on the way up here.
What are you doing Brian?
You're distracting the shit out of him and all this at it.
[inaudible]
you're definitely [inaudible] I haven't been smoking weed for the solid science
from the solid sense of the vapors.
That vaporizer is very good,
but it's not as good as smoking weed.
No,
no,
no.
That's what I'm saying.
It's pretty good.
It's pretty close in the morning.
I think it's the right amount before you go on stage.
That's why the phone I switched up.
Do you have to switch up the capsules because you get used to it?
She got to have a sativa and I got to do that when I smoke weed.
Do the same thing.
Yeah.
You always [inaudible] it up the whole fucking day.
We're different like that though.
I don't mind smoking.
I say we'd all the toxic smoke the same week for like six months.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I live understood.
Stood somebody about bought a pound of weed every time you went out and got the
same fucking weed.
You're killing me.
I got this bitch up.
I think you and I do very different things with the week.
No,
no,
no.
Even if you smoke it like some mornings you want to smoke a,
excuse me.
It's a Tiva.
Some mornings you know you want to the sativas I love Sativa.
I mean and how high are you getting?
Are you getting like stupid high in the mornings anymore?
Like I used to know that like when you were switching to Muslim bro,
when I was waking up and smoking mad,
so g at four 45 of the ham by five 30 you're drooling that Endeca a sativa
fucking grind together.
I get out,
jump in a pool,
you got to do something,
you gotta do something,
you gotta get on a bicycle.
It's like that shit that Lance Armstrong,
I am be,
what would they shoot their legs that they gotta to get up at three in the
fucking morning.
EPL,
same thing.
I was getting that type of reaction from the weed,
which I love.
I love getting a sudden urge to go hit the bag for 30 minutes or glow kits.
I liked that where 15 minutes and you're like,
oh my God,
I'm 15 minutes said right.
Why don't you fucking yeah.
Yeah.
It feels good to move your body around.
Well the thing that comes with weed when you,
you know,
you get,
especially if you get like that full body high,
why like deep indicas you know you get that like real sensitivity to like all of
your body.
Like all the different aspects of your body,
all the different muscle fibers and shit.
You feel it moving around and shit.
I've done everything pretty much.
I've tried pretty much.
I want to live in Colorado tribe,
you know,
a climbing a wall and everything.
The easiest to things I've done high,
which I really enjoy it.
Number one on the list is yoga.
Yoga is amazing.
It's amazing.
Really high.
So it gills I ever bullets better because you get more energy,
your lungs to to hold the poses and shit like that.
They're switching over you like a cookie.
But who's really good at 6:00 AM yoga.
You've got to get up at three 30 feet of fucking that up where you're a savage.
So what they say the best thing with the yoga is the real aficionados eating
hashish.
Hashish.
Yeah,
a little cookie.
And then an hour and 20 minutes later you do the yoga when they've run.
Bruce Lee died.
What was the system?
THC as she,
she neither one.
I mean I'm sure he had some stuff in the system,
but he died from a cerebral,
but I understand that though.
I have nothing with the cause he died from the fucking Yakuza and the fucking
Chinese.
Yeah,
cause they killed them.
He stopped making money.
But you think so?
Yeah.
He once he went over to Warner brothers,
how was I going to clean Colin's damn money?
Is that like the conspiracy theories that,
look,
he made three movies over there.
He made four movies over there.
Right.
But he came over.
He wants to do a and for the dragon.
Then he went back to release the movie and he died or something.
So you think they whacked him?
I don't know what happened,
but I know those movies have made gazillions.
Like they look at all these people,
all,
they made this move for this.
What do you think of cost to make fists of Fury and the Philippines?
50 bucks.
How many millions do you can they've made?
I said,
it's probably the lands.
You know what's crazy if you're looking at in some million,
if you look at,
if you look up,
uh,
what was the producer on those movies?
He did run,
run chow.
I don't,
Raymond Chow was the producers and all those movies that picture after 1973 I
want you to look at how many movies,
you know,
what Amos and when that picture first from,
do you know what I do?
You know it's from Joe where?
Oh,
that's in Florida.
Austin.
Motherfucking that a one place that we always stay at their place.
If you're looking to see you after Bruce Lee died in 73,
how many movies Raymond Chow produced in the u s take a look at Manley called
kick a fucking look.
Don't,
well,
there was a big market for those.
Bruce Lyman.
Not Bruce Lie.
He directed definitely with Charles Bronson,
Wayman Zhao,
a director on the child wants and movie your producer the head.
I don't know.
I wasn't at,
I don't know what's going on here.
Tell me.
Raymond Chow had his own fucking company,
so just called whatever movies,
the movies that fucking luck did.
Joey Diaz is the child is uh,
the old,
no,
I'm not.
I'm not,
I'm a nobody.
I'm just telling you,
he's the allegations
which you motherfuckers forget that you guys were here for the cell phone.
You guys were here for this.
I was here for the six government killed Bruce Lee.
I would know it wasn't no fucking government.
I was here for the Bruce Lee invasion while the people here for the Beatles
invasion,
not me.
I was here for the brute.
I was here when everybody was walking around with Chinese shoes.
Shout with known CFA Raymond Chow.
He's exactly the kind of producer was like every single movie in the road.
Okay.
All before 73 United States.
Look at all those movies and how many of those movies do you
thank?
He got the fuck white girls and how many,
how many were they brought white chicks to him and he just had mad white chick
orgies.
Now before 73 he was enter the Dragon.
What else?
All those goddamn movies.
That's the craziest Shit I've ever seen in my life.
That guy,
that guy that rented a hundred fucking movies.
What are the actual numbers?
Prime.
What does,
how many numbers?
How many movies did he actually direct?
Does it say [inaudible] 60 he produced shit.
But you could like be produced in a couple of different movies at a time.
You can't really,
can you really
look at that paper does keep balling slowly,
slowly,
slowly.
Fuck
I,
but keep going up up,
up the other way.
The other way,
the other way up.
Up.
I'm Sloan out Bra.
Oh He's,
that was the worst one ever.
Look at these movies is mother dead
looking at shit breakthrough.
Look at us.
Keep going.
Let's break through.
Who the fuck knows?
He did the cannonball run one and two about the law.
Oh Wow.
He did ever police story too.
He did everything but the law.
A lot of Chinese movies,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's where the two needs with Ninja turtles too.
And once upon a time in China,
he just muscled themself into those while he just,
they just bring them to him.
What'd you mind being at this?
Look at this.
So walk who?
Everything.
I see Sangha Brown.
You got to stop with that dumb fake gay voice.
That's really in your Internet.
You're,
you're,
you're doing so well.
And then you do that and everybody goes,
God damn it.
Stop it.
You know what it is?
Shut your,
oh,
how dare you.
Shit.
Joey Diaz.
So what's next Joey?
You know me baby.
You know what's fucking,
that was Friday night.
Friday night,
the 21st at eight o'clock we'll turn motherfucking data and meeting the first
edible like at one o'clock in the afternoon.
I'm timing it all perfectly.
I'm doing MGM h at for Promo mixed that of mushrooms,
bath.
Bazookas
I'm doing everything.
We want to extend a formal invitation.
John McAfee,
if you are free in the United States,
we have two tickets for you for the Wiltern theater.
He would sit right next to Brian red band and his date for the evening.
Where you're bringing Brian,
we no hose,
no bath salts at the Wiltern please folks is the end of the world.
We can go bath salt free for one night.
Shall we keep it together?
Joe Diaz,
Doug,
Stan,
hope honey,
honey and me and Doug.
Stan will be on the podcast on Saturday,
the day after the end of the world.
If there is world to return to.
We would do the Doug Stan podcast,
Saturday afternoon.
Dirty fucks.
All right folks.
Oh My,
my,
uh,
specials out.
It's out right now.
So,
um,
if you're a inclined,
if you go to Joe rogan.net,
it's called live from the Tabernacle.
Um,
I think is my best one yet.
It's going to be on iTunes also.
So like maybe eventually through iTunes,
maybe eventually,
but right now it's just through my website for the,
probably the longest time,
maybe like a year or two for the rest of my life.
It's a unprotected file.
So you can just tape it onto like a computer and stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
what is it called?
Drm Free.
Is that what it's called?
Yeah,
no,
it's the same way Louis CK did it.
I completely stole everything he did.
And if you have an apple TV,
all you do is you open it up in iTunes and on the top right hand button you
could send it to your apple TV.
So yeah,
you can just dream.
And there's a lot of ways you can stream it.
Yeah,
there's,
there's all sorts of ways you could watch it on television.
I don't,
I'm not the most technologically inclined,
but we tried to make it as easy as possible and uh,
the feedback has been amazing.
So thank you very much.
I'm,
I'm real excited that so many people decided to date.
Thanks man.
I'm,
I'm very happy.
You know,
like I think what Louie did was really important for us for standup comedians.
his idea was perfect.
It was brilliant.
The amount of money was the right amount of money.
Five bucks is,
I mean he could have made it 10 and probably the same amount of people would
buy,
but five is like really like honest.
It's like,
you know,
you're getting a recording of the live performance,
you're not getting the live performance and so I'll be getting on the recording.
It's worth five bucks.
You'd had the best thing that you're doing awesome.
Is the ability to send it as a gift.
So like I've already sent it to a few people,
like you just put their email address and then you pretty much buy it and then
just send it to them and they get download instructions.
So like you could send it to your friends or families.
We wanted to have it set up like that.
We wanted to have it so that you could send it to people if,
you know,
if you dug it up.
People love sending people like,
like a lot of people send me music.
It's con like that's how we found out about honey honey.
That's how I,
I constantly hear about new bands.
That's how I found out about a roadkill goes choir.
Somebody sent it to me.
I love that.
And people love doing that with comics too.
And so if you want to send mine,
you can do that.
And there's a,
there's a,
you can,
you can gift it.
And um,
Joe,
when he,
when's the next thing that,
uh,
people could see you?
What's the next,
uh,
January 17th at the Irvine Improv after the birth of my fucking daughter.
The next couple of weeks I'll just chill,
kick kickbox and lifting weights.
I'm trying to do everything.
What day is January 17th.
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Thursday.
So that's
a the next time.
And when,
when are you going to release something line?
Because I have no fucking idea.
Let's do that.
Can,
can I produce that?
How about we'll do that.
How about the next thing that I do through talking monkey incorporated.
Dot.
We'll just produce your shit and release it the same way.
Okay.
I'll your webpage.
Yeah.
We'll or yours or whatever.
We'll send yourself the same way.
Okay,
let's do it.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
Let's,
um,
we'll put together,
you know,
a time where we can,
record you at some club and I think for you what would really be bad ass.
One of the cool ways to deal with you is to take you from the fucking green
room,
like one camera from the green room all the way out to this stage.
Follow you through the whole thing.
One,
which just one crazy wild fucking take.
And then you sneak out the back door to four shows,
two four shows,
got picked.
The one you liked the best.
Release the hounds.
Dot.
We could say,
you know,
I get it.
I get these emails from people all the time when it's Joey Coco Diaz going to
have some kind of comedy special.
I always want him to,
one of the talks that squad motherfucker records in full effect and we're going
to be at the Improv third sector.
You're going to be their busiest prop tonight with already,
if the story tellers show great fit something.
A couple of people come on by,
Greg [inaudible],
five bucks,
five bucks and it's a family and it's really fun.
That's a a really a fun time at eight o'clock or eight o'clock Thursday and
prof.com it's the Hollywood improv,
17th of January and Irvine,
but that time you'll have your first check.
Everything will be real for you.
Really get the hopefully or the aliens will have landed and the money will be
worthless.
Those.
Fuck Mel Gibson.
Brian bags are already wearing our NASA outfits,
right?
Because we are volunteering for volunteer NASA because there'll be a volunteer
NASA in the future,
just like volunteer fire department.
I'm just trick doing it because I went to tricare Santa Maria,
they think you're smart move.
I like,
I like what you're doing.
I think it'll work.
I don't know.
I think,
yeah,
I think as long as you make the effort to try to trick her should just play
along and you're golden and then it's like your whole life is like fantasy role
playing game.
That's kind of cool.
You pretend you're the super scientist in NASA and even though you're just
leaving our house,
you telling me you gotta have to go to the moon.
That's a great idea.
I'll print out like fake NASA documents and I would carry them around all the
time out on a clipboard.
It reminds me of a Robin Harris bit.
Robin Harris is one of the last comics that nobody ever talks about and a DL
Hughley sort of,
um,
was influenced by him quite a lot.
Like especially like early in deals career.
You too.
Robin Harris is really,
really funny,
but one of the things he,
uh,
he had a great joke about,
he said a man,
but ain't no pretty woman.
It goes pretty women,
man.
Too much work.
He goes,
well man,
you could tell it anything bitch.
I'm going to the moon.
And he was like,
so like casual and his delivery and like relaxed and he just made you smile.
Just looking
at it with sweet Willie and do the right thing.
And he was tremendous as who's,
who else would have a character name?
Sweet Dick Willie.
Yeah.
I'm going to want me to tell her anything big time going to the moon.
I'll never get listened to that man.
He,
yeah,
I think there's a special called babies kids.
Yeah,
I think you could.
You could.
I don't know if you can watch it,
but you could definitely listen to it.
I used to listen to that shit on cassette.
Okay.
I had that thing on fucking cassette.
I used to listen to that and my Volkswagon Corrado who drive around listening to
Jodi,
TNC,
Yana,
I've always showed him brother,
what's the matter man?
You're not getting sleep.
Are you nervous?
They'll be Kinda,
I was up at fucking fought dirty.
Are you up at the sun and gone with the wind?
Yeah,
I went to bed early last night and got up early.
Yeah.
It's just,
yeah,
you were always up,
man.
I text you at six o'clock in the morning.
He texted me back.
Yeah,
I was ready to rock.
Says I said fucking eight o'clock this morning and we'll go to the kitchen
making a protein shake and fucking going.
Wow.
It's eight o'clock and they have already done 30 fucking things.
That's Robin Harris right there.
Yeah,
right there.
Like I didn't leave the house,
but I had already done dirty fucking things of that house.
Showered breakfast,
protein,
shake emails,
phone calls,
the whole fucking deal.
Reefer.
Have you thought about moving to the suburbs where we're all raised,
their babies get to stay in the hood?
No,
I'm all right.
I'm all right where I'm at.
Be like,
well,
yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going to stay there for a few months.
Not about moving in Nashville too,
Huh?
I taught a lot.
A lot of fucking things.
Talk to honey,
honey,
you'll move there.
They love it there.
I know a lot of people love it except everyone's armed.
They said that's a problem.
Like everybody's know somebody that's been shot.
Well she shot him and then he shot her back and woo,
he's fucking up.
But you don't want to,
I don't run in those circles.
Have you ever seen a the a wild and wonderful whites of West Virginia?
I heard about it.
I'm getting you that for Kras.
Yes.
I don't want to have to get you that.
No circles.
So I'm not worried.
You know,
weapons.
When I did carry a weapon when I was 27 I was a coke dealer and I carried the
Miami vice with the upside down piece with the two clips with 16 and the fuck 14
and how old were you?
I was probably 27 when I thought I was Don Johnson.
And you were just walking around with a gun for how long?
I get paranoid looking at windows fucking night.
Like if I had to go pick up $80 from you had put the gun up like Whoa,
really?
You know,
it's just not that I do it to show it to you,
but I have it on me just in case.
And it was just weird that,
uh,
things would happen around me when I had that gun.
And then one day I stopped wearing the gun and those things disappeared.
So say that before they were magnet brother.
Fuck yeah.
Web Mindset that you have while you're carrying it,
that makes you a magnet for problems.
You know what,
when I carried God was the only time somebody opened that jacket to me one time
and let me know they had a gun on somebody they were with,
you know,
one time it happened in El Paso,
but that's just gonna happen.
I'll pass you by and blow it for the morning with somebody,
his wife,
you know,
I would imagine it'd be a shame.
So,
uh,
just like knives,
I've seen people get stabbed and I got into fights when I'd have a knife on me.
What the fuck am I going to carry a knife on me fucking for,
for what?
You know when you carry it and you know gets cut when you carry a knife,
you do.
You dumb mother fucker.
That's who gets called when you stabbed somebody as shit.
You're not used to.
Even when you train with fucking knives,
you'll cut your hands if they don't have the,
the guards at the end because the shit slips up.
That's the first thing that it's just a,
if you don't know how to use a knife,
you should not fuck with one.
You only going to hurt your fucking hands.
You really are listening.
How many people really know how to use it and not men.
They think they watch fucking Boyz in the hood and all of a sudden they fucking
go out and buy a switch.
But you had no idea.
My friend,
you have no idea when you get a knife,
it's a bone.
The twist and pop side.
I've seen people with knives get the shit knocked out of him pulling out a
fucking knife is him one time at port authority in New York,
I seen something go down.
I call,
you know when you catch the tail end the sentence.
That's what it happened.
This guy pulled out a knife with a stab,
a dude with a leather jacket on human,
no dangerous,
stupid human,
no danger.
Like he hit him in the elbow.
The guy caught it and this guy just knocked off,
flopped out of him,
broke his fucking lip.
It was beautiful.
So you're saying if you live in a dangerous area,
get some chain mail,
gets himself a nice coat of armor.
You have a nice leather jacket,
but who's going to wear that when it's 150 fucking degrees in Atlanta?
When?
How are you going to do that in Atlanta,
New York,
Miami,
there's all listen,
stay in the fucking Monday.
Got Their business.
Even when you carried new checks as a kid,
you met other motherfuckers went blue chucks.
I never carry nunchucks as a kid that you pass that.
That was a great time.
I had a knife for awhile.
I have one of those double o seven new chunks hit everybody you looked at
instead of having tattoos that bruises with everybody carried new chunks.
Everybody had bruises.
The back of their album.
Oh my God.
The fucking mid seventies from Bruce Lee came out like this.
In fist it,
I think he picked the China and Chinese connection.
When he took those new chucks,
it was done.
Then there was another movie that came out called Corrado,
the Hong Kong cat.
That is not documented that I've been hunting for fucking years because his new
Chuck's had copper on the corners.
So this motherfucker took to,
like Bruce Lee took two brooms.
You took a hole,
you're drilling,
you put eye hooks and you took two chains.
Those were new chucks,
not Hong Kong cat.
He took it to a different mother fucking level.
He took two new checks like this,
drilled them,
but instead of putting just a thing and he put metal caps with the eye and then
he put an eye hook into that.
Not to mention the bottom.
He'd go to the hardware store to a plumbing supply and put caps on the bottom,
copper caps and crazy glue Monday.
So when you got hit in the head when you got hit and I would capa instead of
fucking would honk Kong with it.
He had it a whole different dimensions to a new chunk world over that.
And then checks made me realize,
uh,
about the differences in woods.
That's how I found out about different kinds of woods.
Nunchucks cause you would go to like the by him on those catalogs,
they will have like Coco Bolo.
You want to Coco Bolo woodchucks a very dark dense wood.
Very heavy.
Like,
oh those would make some bad ass noon chunks.
That's how I found out about like Coco Bolo and oak.
Like what the harder woods where it was like what they were making nunchucks out
of.
Oh it was the hardest ones.
Vocal Bolo.
Coca Bola was pretty hard as it the hard way.
But if he could get real ebony,
that's really hard to,
it's really hard,
really heavy.
There's some dense dark woods mostly or usually the harder woods,
like ebony is an extremely heavy,
dense wood.
That's why they use it a lot.
Like a lot of people like it for pool cues.
You know,
they will,
they make them out of ebony because it's so dense.
Heavy.
It's just tough to get up an ebony pool cue.
That's like a lightweight one.
You know.
It's crazy though.
I see.
Growing up I see the thousands of white kids with new chucks.
Black people loved who?
Chuck [inaudible] Peterson.
Bruce Lee right there.
Way before this.
The Chinese connection was where he took them to a little bit.
Look at this.
By this time he,
yeah,
the fuckers once he took it from the wound so you can hear it cause it sounds,
it's crazy.
It doesn't have sound.
The video doesn't have sound.
That was July of [inaudible] 73 this fucking country lost and then lost their
mind.
They lost that black people at the movie theater lost their fucking,
I was living in an apartment and the superintendent,
the other word for Chinese collection,
new chuck right there.
Is that it?
Okay.
I was living in this apartment
and the,
the uh,
superintendent that,
uh,
what,
whatever it was.
Yeah.
I guess it was a superintendent.
The guy who takes care of the building,
his family.
He had a son that was like my age and that's how I found out about Bruce Lee.
They're like,
you don't know about Bruce Lee.
I was like,
what's Bruce Lee?
And I went over their house.
They was showing me these,
Bruce Lee puts was like,
whoa.
He had to like a poster,
like enter the Dragon.
You know what the fucking cuts on them with the blood or what is this?
And then,
uh,
I think they took me to see a movie.
You know,
you didn't have VCRs back then.
Seed.
I had to actually go to the movies.
I'm pretty sure they took me to see the first Bruce Lee movie I ever saw.
And I was like,
wow.
Yeah,
this is Chinese connection.
This is a really good together real.
I would've been the fourth grade,
a sacred heart school for boys watching happy days on a Tuesday fucking night.
And all of a sudden right there see the trailer for the Chinese connection and
Joe Rogan losing my fucking mind.
That was a bad ass.
That was his basketball.
Yeah.
There was no crazy character.
Like,
look at the,
who's that guy?
What's his name?
Joe Rogan.
Sam Ohana.
Literally Shit.
This is into things that Sam long.
Yeah,
look at Chuck.
Chuck Norris and him Duking it out.
That's Chuck Norris.
A lot of people don't know you.
They see him money.
He's like 60 years old and Texas ranger and you don't know the history.
Chuck Norris was like a real kickboxing champion,
like one of the first a karate tournament champion in the show.
When I first saw that scene that destroyed America.
That was it.
That after that American never recover from that.
People are eating Chinese food.
Kids were going to China town.
You know,
it completely opened up a new door,
bro.
Instead of going to the fucking,
the roller skating on Saturdays,
we would go into Chinatown.
Well,
you remember when,
remember when people started wearing Chinese slippers?
My mother thought I was crazy.
I used to wear sandals and fucking incense in the house with the that.
That's just amazing.
The Chinese connection is just a tremendous fucking movie.
If you've never seen it.
He's raw and you know he's on the phone with the whole time Joe Rogan and after
this we got to go cause she can't top this.
When he shot the Chinese connection the whole time he's on the phone with Steve
motherfucking McQuade the whole time.
He's like,
what do I do?
I'm just a tiny,
what the fuck do I do?
That's what,
that's what gave me the idea to hang motherfuckers can the Chinese connection,
he killed the mother fuckers and he hung them.
Didn't you like do a take lessons?
Steve McQueen and James James Coburn.
Oh please.
He did.
Didn't you do a movie with James Coburn?
You did something with James Coburn.
What'd you do with them?
Oh I did.
I did a couple of wireless and wireless and episode Harless.
I ended up American gun with them.
What's American gun?
I reckon gun.
There's a movie with,
uh,
about a kid who he's a father is his daughter gets shot by a gun and he does
the,
the background that a gun.
When's,
ah,
when's the next UFC are common to man,
come to one of these?
Well,
I can't go to December 29th and then maybe one of the ones that Jackie,
you got to February.
I miss him too.
Dot.
[inaudible] forth the
dove versus Frankie Edgar and funding.
Remind me Alistair Overeem versus big foot Silva please.
Son Los Vegas.
Please go to that one because that's also the one we have the Gig on Friday
night he got in front of and you know,
look,
I look at this guy.
Think that one's good.
Good.
It is.
I just want to go to the fucking UFC dog.
Well,
come on man.
Let's,
do you ever see your books and I'm think I'm booked for the Irvine one,
but are you booked for that February weekend?
At first I got to look at to the first week of February or the week before that
I'm booking all you motherfuckers have careers now and this is very
disappointing.
Fine.
Korea has done already.
She fears booked every God damn week he was supposed to come with me to Ohio.
Remember that Brian?
We advertise them
book to governors.
Yeah,
he's just taking bookings over this.
The motherfucker.
He's going money taking money.
Needs to call his agent up and tell him he's already booked when if he told the
people on the internet or I should fear you'd be coming to Columbus,
Ohio to fucking go to the
mumble.
Mumble,
mumble,
mumble.
Powerful.
Ari Superior just released to set.
He's going to a release rather his uh,
his second recording,
whatever it is.
DVD,
CD I,
that was my old house man.
How would that Joey Diaz,
yeah,
that was the early we'd spoken day.
So it was like the first year of me smoking weed.
That was my full gaming rig set up,
see all that shit in the background.
Yeah,
it does.
I built that computer behind Joey's head.
I put that mother fucker together myself.
Yep.
I built that thing from scratch.
Motherboard,
add hard drives a whole deal cause I used to do that shit back then.
I used to make my own gaming computers because if you made them you could like,
you know,
under,
you understood like it was really not very hard.
It's really pretty easy.
You just did you follow instructions?
You know,
all you have to do is just put the stuff in the right place to set the jumpers.
Remember that Brian?
Remember setting jumpers?
Yeah,
that was,
it was annoying shit ever.
Yeah.
We used to have to have tweezers and used to have to have them pull these little
plastic things out and stick them in the right slots.
They had to be in the right slots for various reasons.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause he's like,
if you want like certain things had to be on different frequencies and they,
they,
you know,
and then you had to flash your bios.
Oh Jeez.
Shit.
What the fuck?
Joe Diaz,
he never did nothing like that.
He just got a website from Godaddy.
You ever have a hard time changing a fucking flat tire?
When are you doing?
Are you doing the church?
What's happening now on Ustream at all?
No,
I'm still on with the other guys.
Stick Cam.
What do you on steady cam stick yet?
But I'm going to start doing the show live with them on Wednesdays.
The Nerdist studios.
Oh,
beautiful.
What is it that the calming is kind of the day though in the morning at 6:00 AM,
but they have a comic book stories now where they have it set up.
Hit the fucking standup is off the chain.
Well,
let you got a fucking night.
They're Red Bay,
uh,
30 studios.
I had the fucking,
one night there were two of the people watching comedies.
They tell me you can't even get parking spots down there.
Wow.
Nerdist studio.
Well,
you know,
is that the comic Book Stars Meltdown,
right?
Oh yeah.
I used to go there before.
Nervous.
Is that right?
It's really small though.
Ooh,
it's 200 people.
But to have a back room.
Right.
Um,
let's do a show next week after the end of the world at the
Wednesday we go ahead and start calling you and you said Christmas or something.
So Wednesday,
is it Christmas?
Oh,
it's the 26th I'll be out of town.
26 what does the next Wednesday,
is it the 26th yeah,
a showing Bray with Doug Benson,
I believe.
Yeah,
it is a 26.
Okay.
Yeah.
And we can't do a show the day after Christmas.
We did that Friday though.
Friday that Friday,
that Friday I'm gone.
Where are you?
I'm in Vegas.
Cause
is this casino?
Like what about Thursday?
Thursday,
Thursday.
Uh Huh.
No I don't.
Let's do a powerful desk watch show Thursday night.
All right,
well either way we're,
yeah,
we'll figure it out.
We'll see what the Wednesday or Thursday.
He love you mother fuckers every Christmas.
I love you guys.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for all the love you fucking savages.
We love the fuck of all of you.
You have
a third in Irvine show that night.
I'm with Doug Benson and Irvine Improv and the 27th which is Thursday.
What do you got?
Nothing.
Oh,
nothing.
so Thursday is good for you.
Good for you.
Thursday or Friday?
Friday,
Friday.
Friday's Vegas.
Right leg.
Not that weekend,
man.
Waiting until February.
February rolls around.
I had a lot of things happen.
A man first week of February,
if there is a world left,
will be a,
we're going to do the Mandalay bay convention center.
We'll doing the big room where they do the [inaudible] shit.
So it's like 3000 people.
Come on man.
I gotta I need even need some joy.
Does not show you're doing it.
I committed mother fucker.
Commit who?
Whoever who could to possibly tell you to do something other than what you want
to do.
Well,
do you have a calendar on your phone?
I do have it.
Make some shit happen.
Let me match numbers.
At least Jesus.
We get the sand manual casino tomorrow.
Oh come on man.
That's where the less black show is that we're seeing manual together.
Fucking far dog [inaudible] afternoon.
Is that like west palms or no,
you got to go early.
Like three is shot.
It's where the drug mules stop.
Oh fuck this.
Like this is a special meeting room and the bathroom at that casino talk like,
come on man.
Listen,
but out here in Nashville for awhile and a lot of pretty girls love y'all.
Parker Parker talking about some,
a karate look at what was going a big believer in the arts.
This doesn't look that bad,
but I don't want to own their own down.
I don't look like that.
You know what's important is that they show this old Indian dude,
why don't you guys show me some hot bitches that are also going to this casino?
Why are you showing me an old Indian?
There has to be a hot pitch right here.
Yeah,
you don't have to show me a dream catcher.
He's saying a fucking Stephen King Book.
Okay.
Show me some hot bitches.
I get it.
It's an Indian casino.
I got it.
I get it.
You're not advertising the correct way.
Old Indians rarely get people to go visit him.
Where he got that girl in the corner.
She's fucking barely finder,
cold hard cash.
Those,
um,
those,
uh,
those places are interesting.
We used to go to,
well there's,
or that's pretty girl.
We used to go to a lot of those Indian casinos back in the day when I'm mixed.
Martial arts was illegal in California.
Eddie Bravo and I used to drive out to,
uh,
to see the king of the cages and shit.
We used to go out.
They were always in these.
It's funny,
right when you said it pulled up king in a cage.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Well can you have the cage is a good,
uh,
I think that's Tony Lopez.
A King of the cage is a good January.
No,
go back to Canaan.
December one December 20th tomorrow.
What does that do?
That's just,
I'm going to be there to save time as king a cage.
Fuck Dude.
Ah,
no,
no.
That's Thursday.
No,
no.
It was December 20th I said Wednesday,
December 19th December 19th and the way it,
oh,
it's way.
Ah,
okay.
You lucked out the man.
Well,
if you're going to king cage,
do you want to see us?
The comedy stylings of today's the blacker today's the 18th
Wednesday,
so when you're going to be there,
you've got tomorrow,
Wednesday.
We're going to be there.
When they're grumpy,
you're going to be there when they're cutting weight and all their teams are
getting amped up and staring each other down.
Dual job bitch going down.
Pitch.
A lot of good fighters there though.
Mike capps is there January 17th.
He can't help you and he can help me today.
You know,
it's like that fucking little Wayne video.
He,
you know,
he can't save you.
You know,
he can't save you
the Ohio players in the real world,
in the real world.
He can't save you client.
Oh,
that's a good Brian.
I wish you luck and your uh,
your quest to make black people out.
I suggest you not do any of your racist jokes.
No,
I will not.
I only have one black Joe.
It's barely racers and spare.
I'm on your side,
but I suggest to dance around that and start strong.
You've got to start strong and no slurring,
no smoking weed before that.
No probate Joe.
Maybe a little bit of that property or you need to get yourself a doctor.
I know.
Powerful Joe Diaz.
Thank you very much for joining us,
man.
As always,
I love the fucking shit out of you.
You do it right and we're going to have a good God damn time this Friday at the
end of the world show.
Thank you to audible.com go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
get yourself heard by free and one free audio book.
It's in a an amazing surface service.
It amazing.
I almost like surface.
Then I realized what I was saying as I was saying it.
It's an amazing serve.
This,
I use it,
uh,
use it for a while and the book I'm reading from it right now is called sex at
dawn by Christopher Ryan who will be on the podcast soon.
We're,
we're going back and forth about this right now,
but I got a lot of people booked already.
Bitches,
shit is blowing up.
I'm hooking you up with some fresh guests.
I talked to Tom Green.
He wants to do it.
Come back on powerful Tom Green.
I want Tom Green on.
I was really impressed with Tom Green special.
Um,
I watched for comedy specials in a row,
which I don't usually do.
And Tom Green was the one that made me laugh and I thought that was really
awesome because you know,
Tom Green's only been doing standup for like five years.
I think he has really been good that long.
We had him on the,
on that podcast last night,
and he was saying that he,
he sold his whole entire studio.
He had a TV studio in his house.
He sold the whole thing and just got rid of all his stuff that's not there in
his house anymore.
And he's now just thinking about coming back and doing a podcast now again.
Uh,
but,
uh,
he's just going to get focused on comedy.
Yeah.
Well,
you can tell,
you can tell if you see his last special.
It was really good.
I think he did it from Australia.
I want to say he did it from Australia.
I might not be right about that though,
but whatever it was,
it was really good.
I mean,
Tom's a,
and he's a great guy.
I would love to have them on.
And,
uh,
so that's it.
Doug.
Stan hope will be joining us.
You dirty bitches on a Saturday.
That's depending on whether or not Saturday actually exists.
Don Tom.
But we got a lot of cool guests coming up,
including,
uh,
Steve Volk,
the author of fringe Ology Stever.
Knella is going to be on in a January.
We got to get a talk about my hunting trip with him.
Successful.
That's right.
Brody and joy.
Yet successful hunter got meet positive energy.
Go see Brody Stevens anytime you can and when you see him,
give him a fucking hug for all of us because we love the shit out of him.
We've got to get Brian Holtzman on this podcast too.
Can you make contact with him,
Brian?
We're going to find them folks.
We're going to bring him to you.
All right.
Follow mad flavor on Twitter.
That is Joey Diaz.
His handle.
I know it's not Joey Diaz.
I know it's confusing,
but if you put it in Joey Diaz in the search engine,
mad flavors,
the first one that shows up,
you can do it.
You fucks.
Keep it together.
Thank you to [inaudible] dot com use the code name,
rogue it.
Then that's o n n I t.com.
Use the code name Rogan and save yourself
this shirt or this show yet.
The Tim Ferriss and his show.
Uh Oh,
Tim Ferriss was on media there as well.
Yeah,
he's a meter and look,
he's on,
they're wearing a death squad shirt.
Oh,
that's awesome.
He went on the BD test squad shirt.
That is the shit.
What a cool guy.
Tim Ferriss.
I love that guy.
Check out this sportsman channel.
Wow.
Him.
If I could get him,
Karen,
Maria,
and Dave Asprey in the room all at one time,
I really think that I could be smarter.
I will rise to and Dennis Mckenna,
all of them together talking together.
I will,
I will absorb their energy and become smarter.
Tim Ferriss is cool as fuck.
Thank you,
Tim.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah,
and we'll have him on again fucking for sure.
Without a doubt.
All right folks,
this is the last episode in the 300 episode series.
Ooh,
yeah.
300 episodes.
All we want.
Yeah,
we hit syndication.
We're,
we're,
you know,
listen or to beat.
We didn't start this thing off thinking it would ever become what it is now.
We,
we,
you know,
we just started off for a goof and three years later,
here we are and we've had a great fucking time.
We appreciate all you piece of people that say nice things about it that enjoy
it and say that it enhances your life and it enhances ours too.
We would never get to have,
even though we have cool friends like Joey Diaz and you know Doug Stan hope and
all these people,
it's really hard to get all these people to sit down and talk with you for three
hours at a time like this unless you broadcasting it.
There's the fact that it's going out to all you actually benefits us just as
much as it benefits you.
So we're all in this together.
You fucks.
All right.
Keep it together and we'll see you on Saturday or we'll see you Friday at the
end of the world show.
We'll see you Thursday at the Improv.
I wouldn't lie to you at night.
I don't know.
What the fuck are you doing?
I might run in the out there out in the wild.